ASSEMBLY MEMBER GIPSON NOTICES
THE ABSENCE OF A QUORUM THE
SERGEANTS AT ARMS WILL PREPARE
THE CHAMBER AND BRING IN THE
ABSENT MEMBERS AND THE CLERK
WILL CALL THE ROLL.
AGUIAR-CURRY ARAMBULA.
BAUER-KAHAN BERMAN. BIGELOW
BLOOM. BOERNER HORVATH BONTA.
BRO BURKE CALDERON CARILLO
CERVANTES CHAU CHEN DAVID CHIU
CHOI KANSEN CHU COOLEY COOPER
CUNNINGHAM DALY DALY DEEP.
EGGMAN FLORA FONG FRAZIER
FRIEDMAN GABRIEL GALLAGHER
CRISTINA GARCIA EDUARDO GARCIA
GIPSON GLORIA GONZALEZ GRAY
GRAYSON HOLDEN IRWIN JONES
SAWYER KALRA KAMLAGER KILEY
LACKEY LEVINE LIMON LOW
MAIENSCHEIN MATHIS MAYES
MCCARTY MEDINA MELENDEZ MULLIN
MURATSUCHI NAZARIAN OBERNOLTE
O'DONNELL PATTERSON
PETRIE-NORRIS QUIRK QUIRK SILVA
RAMOS RAMOS THREE OF US ROBERT
REED THIS RODRIGUEZ RUBIO SALAS
SANTIAGO SMITH STONE TING
VOEPEL. WALDRON WEBER WICKS
WOOD MISTER SPEAKER.
MEMBERS A
QUORUM IS PRESENT. MEMBERS A
QUORUM IS PRESENT IN THE
ASSEMBLY. WE ASK OUR GUESTS AND
VISITORS IN THE REAR OF THE
CHAMBER AND IN THE GALLERY TO
PLEASE STAND FOR THE PRAYER.
TODAY'S PRAYER WILL BE OFFERED
BY OUR ASSEMBLY CHAPLAIN THE
REVEREND PETTY OSHA RIVER NEXT.
PLEASE JOIN ME IN A MOMENT OF
REFLECTION. GROWING UP I WOULD
HEAR MY GRANDPARENTS GREETING
PEOPLE EACH NEW YEAR ADDING THE
PHRASE QUARTO SHE MORE YOUR
SCHOOL ON A GUY SHE MáS. A
CLOSE TRANSLATION WOULD BE THIS
YEAR AGAIN I WILL BE RELYING ON
YOUR HELP KINDNESS AND SUPPORT.
THIS THE AWFUL EXPRESSION
ACKNOWLEDGES THAT WE CANNOT
EXIST SIMPLY BY OURSELVES. MORE
DEEPLY REFLECTS THE WARN US
THAT ALL HUMAN BEINGS WE NEED
EACH OTHER NOTHING CAN EXIST IN
A VACUUM NO INDIVIDUAL NO
COMMUNITY NO NATION CONNECT THE
EXIST ALONE IN THE VACUUM. WE
NEED EACH OTHER TO NOT SIMPLY
LIVE TO GIVE MEANING TO OUR
LIVES. WITH THE LUNAR NEW YEAR
BEGINNING JUST TWO DAYS AGO.
LET ME EXPRESS MY LUNAR NEW
YEAR GREETINGS AND GRATITUDE BY
SAYING QUOTE THOUGH SHE MORE
EURO SCHOOL ON THE GUY SHE
MáS. THIS YEAR AGAIN I WILL BE
RELYING ON YOUR HELP KINDNESS
IS SUPPORT FOR ALL OF YOU HELP
GIVE MEANING TO MY LIFE. NUMBER
ONE THE NUMBER SEE WITH
KINDNESS AND GRATITUDE BEYOND
WORDS. THANK YOU REVEREND WE
ASK OUR GUESTS AND VISITORS TO
REMAIN STANDING AND JOIN US FOR
THE FLAG SALUTE PLEASE JOIN
ASSEMBLY MEMBER DAVID CHIU AS
HE LEADS US IN THE PLEDGE
MISTER CHIP THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER HAPPY LUNAR NEW YEAR
PLEASE PLACE YOUR HAND OVER
YOUR HEART AND REPEAT AFTER ME.
I PLEDGE ALLEGIANCE TO THE FLAG
OF THE UNITED STATES OF AMERICA.
THANK YOU MAY BE. READING THE
PREVIOUS DAY'S JOURNAL ASSEMBLY
CHAMBER SACRAMENTO TUESDAY
JANUARY FOURTEENTH TWENTY
TWENTY THE ASSEMBLY MET AT
SEVEN AM ON WILL JIM PATTERSON
ASSEMBLY MEMBER TWENTY THIRD
DISTRICT PRESIDING CHIEF CLERK
SUE PARKER AT THE DESK READING
CLICK KATHLEEN AND LOUIS
READING THE BALLING A PLACE
HOLDER A GIPSON MOVES. AND
MISTER LACKEY SECONDS. THAT THE
READING OF THE PREVIOUS DAY'S
JOURNAL BE DISPENSED WITH.
PRESENTATIONS HAVE PETITIONS
THERE ARE NONE. INTRODUCTION
REFERENCE TO BILLS WILL BE
DEFERRED REPORTS OF COMMITTEES
WILL BE DEEMED READ AND
AMENDMENTS DEEMED ADOPTED
MESSAGES FROM THE GOVERNOR
THERE ARE NONE MESSAGES FROM
THE SENATE THERE ARE NONE.
MOVING TO MOTIONS AND
RESOLUTIONS THE ABSENCES FOR
THE DAY FOR ILLNESS SPEAKER
ANTHONY RENDON FOR MATERNITY
LEAVE ASSEMBLY MEMBER SABRINA
CERVANTES.
READ MISTER CALDERON
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED FOR YOUR
PROCEDURAL MOTIONS THANK YOU
MISTER SPEAKER I REQUEST
UNANIMOUS CONSENT TO SUSPEND
ASSEMBLY ONE EIGHTEEN A TO
ALLOW SOMETHING MEMBERS KANSEN
CHU THREE OF US REYES AND TING
TO HAVE GUESTS AND
PHOTOGRAPHERS ON THE FLOOR. MR
TING WAS RAY AS IN MR CHOOSE
GUESTS WILL BE SEATED AT THEIR
DESKS. WITHOUT OBJECTION SUCH
SHALL BE THE ORDER THANK YOU
MISTER SPEAKER I ALSO REQUEST
UNANIMOUS CONSENT TO SUSPEND
ASSEMBLY RULE FORTY FIVE POINT
FIVE. TWO ALLOWS FAMILY MEMBERS
BONTA GRAY TO SPEAK ON AND
GERMAN IN MEMORY TODAY. AGAIN
WITHOUT OBJECTION SUCH SHALL BE
THE ORDER. MEMBERS IF I COULD
HAVE YOUR ATTENTION PLEASE.
MEMBERS MAY PLEASE HAVE YOUR
RESPECTFUL ATTENTION. AS WE ALL
KNOW YESTERDAY NINE PERSONS
DIED IN A TRAGIC HELICOPTER
CRASH IN CALABASAS. TO
MEMORIALIZE THE VICTIMS OF THAT
TRAGEDY. PLEASE RISE AND LET US
NOW OBSERVE A MOMENT OF SILENCE.
THANK YOU MEMBERS MEMBERS THIS
THURSDAY THE ASSEMBLY WILL
HONOR THE VICTIMS AND THEIR
LOVED ONES WITH A MORE FORMAL
ADJOURNMENTS IN MEMORY. THANK
YOU. MEMBERS WE ARE MOVING TO
SPECIAL GAS INTRODUCTIONS WE
HAVE GUESTS WITH US IN THE
CHAMBER TODAY. MR TANG I WOULD
LIKE TO RECOGNIZE YOU FOR YOUR
GAS INTRODUCTION. THANK YOU
MISTER SPEAKER A MONO TO
INTRODUCED AGAIN TO THE
ASSEMBLY FOR MY DAUGHTER MADDIE
TANK AND SHE'S HERE WITH THE
FOURTH GRADE HER FOURTH GRADE
CLASS FROM JOSE ORTEGA
ELEMENTARY SCHOOL THE WANT TO
WELCOME YOU ALL FOR BEING HERE
TO GUIDE LEGISLATURE. HERE
MISTER CHIU KANSEN CHU ARE LIKE
TO RECOGNIZE YOU AS WELL. THANK
YOU MISTER SPEAKER SENT KHALID
MY WIFE DAISY AND I ARE HERE TO
WISH YOU ALL A VERY HAPPY
PROSPERS HEALTHY YOU'RE OFF THE
REST THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
MEMBERS WITHOUT OBJECTION WE
ARE GOING TO MOVE DIRECTLY TO
THE ASSEMBLY THIRD READING
FILES SO MR TANG MAY TAKE UP.
FILE ITEM THIRTY TWO. THIS IS
HOUSE RESOLUTION. SEVENTY TWO
BY MR TANG. THE CLERK WILL READ
HOUSE RESOLUTION SEVENTY TWO BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER TING AND OTHERS
RELATIVE TO THE LUNAR NEW YEAR.
WISHING YOU MAY OPEN. THANK YOU
FOR SPEAKER IT'S MY HONOR TODAY
TO PRESENT ON BEHALF OF THE API
LEGISLATIVE CAUCUS HOUSE
RESOLUTION SEVENTY SEVENTY TWO
WHICH IS RECOGNITION OF THE
LUNAR NEW YEAR- THE LUNAR NEW
YEAR BEGAN THIS PAST SATURDAY
JANUARY TWENTY FIFTH AND WE
WELCOMED IN THE YEAR OF THE
RAT. UNLIKE WHAT WERE USED TO
THE ROUTE IS THE BEGINNING
ANIMAL OF OUR LUNAR NEW YEAR
ACTION IS A VERY GOOD ANIMALS
BUT DOESN'T HAVE ANY NEGATIVE
KIND OF LIKE IT THIS ARKAN
AND MANY A ANCESTRY SO THIS NEW
YEAR IT'S WELL OUR BIG HOLIDAY
IT'S A TIME WHEN FAMILY
TOGETHER. REALLY TO STE A NEW
YOU CAN YOUR HOME TO CALL OF
HAVE A NEW STAR TO THE NEW YEAR
WE HAVE A NUMBER OF A GIFTS FOR
THE DIFFERENT MEMBERS WE HAVE
ORANGE. WHICH REALLY SYMBOLIZES
OUR FAMILY AND FAMILY UNITY
IT'S CIRCULAR IN NATURE. WE
ALSO HAVE THE FAMOUS RED
ENVELOPE. BUT UNLIKE. UNLIKE
MOST CASES WE DO WE WOULD PUT
MONEY AND IT'S OUR FATHERS
TYLER'S LAUGHING OR MIKE MIKE
MY COLLEAGUES IN GARDEN GROVE
IS LAPPING APOLOGIZE. USUALLY
WE PUT MONEY IN THE RED
ENVELOPE AND IT'S SOMETHING
THAT ELDERS GIVE TO YOUNGER
FOLKS DURING THIS TIME OF NEW
YEAR'S OF COURSE ARE GROWING UP
WHEN I WAS A KID GETTING A RED
ENVELOPE FROM. MY PARENTS MY
AUNTS MY UNCLES ALL OUR
RELATIVES OR FRIENDS WAS REALLY
ONE OF THE BIGGEST HIGHLIGHTS
OF THE YEAR AND THE LAST WE
HAVE. A PICTURE OF THE OF THE
RACK AND IS ONLY ACCESSIBLE AND
REALLY. WELCOMING IN THE
BEGINNING OF THIS TWELVE YEARS
THE CHINESE ZODIAC IN THIS THIS
FIGURES ALSO SPECIAL TO BE MY
THERE IS A ROCK. THE WILL TO
CELEBRATE THE BUSINESS ON ITS
IT'S A BIG YEAR FOR HIM OF SO
WHERE TO SELL THE NEW YEAR
TOGETHER WITH OUR FAMILY SO
AGAIN. WE HOPE THAT. YOU KNOW
YOU MIGHT HAVE JOINT. JOINING
IN ON ALL THE FESTIVITIES. THE
JUST. THIS WEEKEND IF NOT WE
REALLY HOPE. TO SEE YOU AT THE
MAY FAST. ALL OVER CAL. REAL
SUPPORTING. VERY IMPORTANT HOW
THANK YOU. THANK YOU MISTER
TAKE. SEEING NO OTHER YES
DOCTOR CHOI YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
I ALSO WANNA AND THE HAPPY LOW
NO YEAR TO EVERY MEMBER OR SO
AND- AS HAPPEN MONEY BY THE SE-
ALL OF AND- THE ONE IS MISSING
THEM. WALLACH AND OF THAT IS TO
HAVE WELL HOW NEW YEAR TO
HAPPEN MONEY BY THE CITY OR IS
IN YOUR- OUR AND THE LAW BY THE
CORE DEAR THIS ONCE AS- IS
BLAST SO WE A LOST SO BLESSINGS
SO YOU NEED THE A SENIOR CHOIR.
AND THOSE TO HAPPEN MONEY BY
THE CEO I WOULD YOU A NEW YEAR
TO EVERYBODY. THANK YOU DOCTOR.
SENIOR MEMBERS SEEKING MISTER
TO WOULD YOU LIKE CO AUTHOR ON
THERE IS A PLACE MR TING
REQUEST THAT THE FOR ROLL THE
FOR CO AUTHORS ON H. R. SO TWO
PROBLEM ROLE MEMBERS IS FOR CAO
OFF. THIS IS FOR HELLO. ADDING
ON THE. THE CLERK WELL. CLOSER
ALL THEIR SIXTY NINE CO AUTHORS
ADDED ON THE RESOLUTION AND
WITHOUT OBJECTION WE MAY TAKE A
VOICE VOTE ON THE RESOLUTION
ALL THOSE IN FAVOR SAY AYE AYE
OPPOSED SAY NAY THE AYES HAVE
IT THE RESOLUTION IS ADOPTED.
MEMBERS WE ARE MOVING BACK TO
GAS INTRODUCTIONS WE HAVE A
NUMBER OF SPECIAL GAS IN THE
CHAMBER WITH US TODAY. IS RAMOS
I SEE THE YOU HAVE GUESTS WITH
YOU ON THE FLOOR YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED. THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER MEMBERS I'DLIKE TO
HAVE YOU JOIN ME IN WELCOMING
MY HUSBAND FRANK RADIOS WAS
HERE TO CELEBRATE MY BIRTHDAY
WITH ME. AND ALSO THE YES MISS
RAISE YOUR REGULAR RECOMMEND
ALSO HERE TO CELEBRATE WITH ME
ON MY THIRTY NINTH WEDDING
ANNIVERSARY. CONGRATULATIONS TO
YOU BOTH.
MEMBERS. MEMBERS
PLEASE DIRECT YOUR ATTENTION TO
THE REAR OF THE CHAMBER TO MISS
READ TO WILL ADDRESS AS FROM MY
DESK. ON THE FLOOR MS REQUESTS
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED THANK YOU
MISTER SPEAKER AND MEMBERS I
RISE TODAY WITH GREAT PRIDE AND
ENTHUSIASM TO INTRODUCE MY
FRIEND CONSTITUENTS FELLOW SAN
FERNANDO HIGH SCHOOL ALUMNI.
AND THE NEWLY ELECTED PRESIDENT
OF THE LOS ANGELES CITY COUNCIL
NERI MARTINEZ. THE PRESIDENT
MARTINEZ BECAME THE FIRST LIKE
THE NOT TO EVER BE ELECTED
PRESIDENT OF THE LOS ANGELES
CITY COUNCIL IN ITS ONE HUNDRED
AND SEVENTY YEAR HISTORY. THIS
IS A HISTORIC MOMENT FOR
LETTING US FOR THOSE WHO MIGHT
NOT BE FAMILIAR WITH LOS
ANGELES POLITICS. LET ME BE THE
ONE TO TELL YOU THAT THIS
POSITION WILL TREMENDOUS POWER.
SINCE BEING ELECTED TO THE CITY
COUNTY. COUNCIL PRESIDENT
MARTINEZ HAS DRAWN FROM HER
EXPERIENCE AS A WOMAN OF COLOR
AND AS THE DAUGHTER OF WORKING
CLASS MEXICAN IMMIGRANTS. TO
ADDRESS THE ISSUES THAT MATTER
THE MOST TO LOS ANGELES.
COUNCIL PRESIDENT MARTINEZ HAS
BEEN AT THE FOREFRONT OF THE
FIGHT TO RAISE THE MINIMUM
WAGE. PROVIDE PAID FAMILY LEAVE
TO NEW PARENTS AND ADDRESS THE
DISPROPORTIONATE IMPACT THAT
CLIMATE CHANGE IS HAVING AMONG
LOW INCOME COMMUNITIES OF
COLOR. BY PROPOSING A GREEN NEW
DEAL FOR THE CITY OF LOS
ANGELES. SHE IS ALSO WORKING TO
FIND NEW STRATEGIES TO PREVENT
AND THE HOMELESS EPIDEMIC OUR
CITY IS CURRENTLY FACING.
HOWEVER PRESIDENT MARTINEZ HAS
NOT JUST BEEN AN ADVOCATE FOR
LOW INCOME COMMUNITIES AND
THOSE WHO ARE LESS FORTUNATE.
SHE HAS ALSO BEEN A FIERCE
LEADER FOR WOMEN'S RIGHTS AND
FEMALE EMPOWERMENT. IN TWENTY
FIFTEEN FOR EXAMPLE SHE
ESTABLISHED THE OPERATIONS
VALLEY BUREAU ON HUMAN
TRAFFICKING TASK FORCE. AND AN
EFFORT TO. IT IS. MEN TRY. AND
GET THE IS THE THEY NEED.
COUNSEL MARTINE ALSO STOP THE
RED FOR WHEN FELLOW PROGRAM. TO
ENCOURAGE YOUNG WHEN TO ENTER
PUBLIC SERVICE AND HER FOR BUT-
AND- INNOVATIVE LEADERS. FOR
ANGELES AND OUR STAY. SINCE
THEY WERE ESTABLISHED IN TWO
FOUR TO. TWENTY THREE YOUNG
WOMEN HAVE COMPLETED FELLOWSHIP.
AND HAVE GONE ON TO EARN FULL
TIME. IN PUBLIC SERVICE. I CAN
LISTING THE MANY OF COUNCIL
PRESIDENT MARTINEZ BUT WE WOULD
NEED THE WHOLE WEEK FOR ME TO
DO THAT. BUT MEMBERS I WANT TO
END WITH THIS. I HAD THE GREAT
HONOR TO ATTEND THE LA CITY
COUNCIL MEETING- WERE NEAR YOU
GAVE HER FIRST SPEECH AS THE
PRESIDENT OF THE COUNCIL THAT
TOOK PLACE TWO WEEKS AGO. AS I
SAT AND- LISTENED TO HER
DESCRIBE HER VISION FOR THE
FUTURE OF LOS ANGELES I COULD
NOT FEEL MORE PROUD OF HOW FAR
SHE HAS COME. IN ALL THE LIVES
THAT SHE HAS TOUCHED ALONG THE
WAY. WHEN MARIE AND I WERE
GROWING UP. THERE WERE NO WOMEN
THAT LOOK LIKE US IN DECISIONS
OF POWER. WE ARE HERE SAY
REPRESENT. MATTERS TODAY I'M
COURAGE TO KNOW THAT GIRLS ALL
OVER OUR STATE CAN SEE THAT
HARD WORK AND DEDICATION ANY
DREAM IS WITHIN REACH. THANK
YOU MY FRIEND FOR SHATTERING
YET ANOTHER GLASS CEILING AND
PROVIDING OUR DREAMS TO BE
LIMITLESS THANK YOU.
MEMBERS I
WOULD ALSO LIKE TO RECOGNIZE.
THE SECRETARY OF STATE THE
HONORABLE ALEX PADILLA IN THE
REAR OF THE CHAMBER CLOSER.
MEMBERS WE HAVE ADDITIONAL
SPECIAL GAS THAT HAVE JOINED
US. FOR SESSION TODAY MS QUIRK
SILVA YOU ARE RECOGNIZED FOR
YOUR SPECIAL GUEST INTRODUCTION.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER MISTER
SPEAKER AND MEMBERS IT IS WITH
GREAT PLEASURE THAT TODAY I
WELCOME MEMBERS OF NORTH ORANGE
COUNTY COMMUNITY COLLEGE
DISTRICT. THESE LEADERS ARE
HERE TO SPEND TIME AT OUR
CAPITAL TO WORK ON LEADERSHIP
THEY HAVE COMPETED IN ORDER TO
GAIN THIRTY SLOT WHERE THIRTY
DISTRICT TO AFFECT CHANGE WITH
IN THE SCHOOL DISTRICT ON
STUDENT SUCCESS IN
INSTITUTIONAL TRANSFORMATION.
THE ACADEMY OFFERS PARTICIPANTS
AN OPPORTUNITY ADVANCED SKILLS
AND DEVELOP THEIR OWN CAPACITY
TO LEAD THE- THE ACADEMY ALSO
FOCUSES ON STRAINS THAT ARE ON
PROJECT. BASED APPROACH TO
DEVELOPING LEARNING AND TO
ADVANCING THE DISTRICT GOALS
THIS ACADEMY DON'T SCHOOLS ARE
LEADING ENVISIONING INNOVATING
ADVOCATING MUNICH EIGHTEEN AND
NETWORK. MEMBERS JOIN ME IN
WELCOMING OUR NORTH ORANGE
COUNTY COMMUNITY HELLO. ACADEMY.
LEADERS. IN HIS RACE YOU HAVE
ADDITIONAL GAS THAT A JOIN US
TODAY. THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER
MEMBERS. PLEASE HELP ME IN
WELCOMING TO THE CAPITAL THE
COLTON ELECTRIC DEPARTMENT FROM
THE CITY MY FAMOUS LITTLE CITY
OF COLTON WITH US HERE IS A
FRIEND OF MANY YEARS REBEKAH IT
GOES. ALSO MY EPIX PARTNER AND
A COLLEAGUES NOT NOTED AND
JESSICA TOWARDS. THE. CALL TO
LET YOUR DEPARTMENT IS THE
LARGEST AND OLDEST MUNICIPAL
UTILITY IN SAN BERNARDINO
COUNTY AND IT IS THE MEETING
THE ELECTRIC NEEDS OF COLSON'S
BUSINESSES AND RESIDENTS SINCE
EIGHTEEN NINETY FIVE. TODAY THE
DEPARTMENT SERVES APPROXIMATELY
NINETEEN THOUSAND CUSTOMERS
WITH A DIVERSE MIX OF
GENERATION RESOURCES MEMBERS
PLEASE JOIN ME WITH GETTING A
WARM WELCOME TO THE FULL TEN
ELECTRIC DEPARTMENT. MEMBERS WE
ARE NOW MOVING TO BUSINESS ON
THE DAILY FILE. SECOND READING
CORPORATE. ASSEMBLY BILL THIRTY
ONE THREE TWENTY TWO THREE
TWENTY SIX FOR AWAIT
640-664-0873 279-838-9890.
SEVEN ELEVEN FORTY FOURTEEN
TWENTY SIX FORTY FIFTY EIGHT
SIXTEEN OH EIGHT SIXTEEN TWO
OH SEVEN. ALL BILLS HAVE BEEN
AMENDMENTS ADOPTED. FILE ITEM
TWENTY SHALL BE CONTINUED. YEAH.
FILE ITEM. TWENTY TWO KERKORIAN.
IT'S ONLY ONE SIXTY TWO BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER KILEY ANOTHER
DIRECTLY TO COMMUNICATIONS.
DOES ANY MEMBER OBJECT TO
GRANTING UNANIMOUS CONSENT TO
MISTER KILEY TO BRING UP AB.
ONE SIXTY TWO. SEEING AND
HEARING NINE THE CLERK WILL
READ. RECONSIDERATION IS
GRANTED CARPAL RATE ASSEMBLY
BILL ONE SIXTY TWO BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER KILEY ANOTHER
DIRECTLY TO COMMUNICATIONS. MR
KILEY YOU MAY OPEN THANK YOU
MISTER SPEAKER AB ONE SIXTY TWO
WILL PROHIBIT THE PUBLIC
UTILITIES COMMISSION FROM
COLLECTING FOR DEPOSIT AND
UNIVERSAL SERVICE FUND ANY
REVENUES DRIVING CHARGES UPON
THE PROVISION OF A
COMMUNICATIONS SERVICE THE
FEDERAL COMMUNICATIONS
COMMISSION HAS DETERMINED AS AN
INFORMATION SERVICE THE BILL
PASSED OUT OF COMMITTEE WITH
UNANIMOUS BIPARTISAN SUPPORT.
AND HAS NO OPPOSITION THANK YOU
ASKED YOUR EITHER. THANK YOU
MISTER KILEY. SEE NO DISCUSSION
OR DEBATE ON THE ITEM. CLICK
CLICK THE WRONG MEMBERS. THE
DESIRE TO VOTE ALL MEMBERS VOTE.
THE DESIRE TO VOTE. ALL MEMBERS
VOTE DESIRE TO VOTE.
MR KILEY.
THIS KILEY MOVES CALL. ITEMS
TWENTY THREE THROUGH TWENTY SIX
ON RECONSIDERATION ARE TO BE
CONTINUED. MOVING TO THE
ASSEMBLY THIRD READING FILE.
FILE ITEMS. TWENTY SEVEN THREE
TWENTY NINE. PASS RETAIN.
BRINGS US TO FILE ITEM THIRTY.
THE FILE ITEM THIRTY IS AB NINE
OH FOR CORPORATE. ASSEMBLY BILL
NINE OH FOUR BY SOME REMEMBER
CHAO ANDACTUALLY TO SEARCH
WARRANTS ISSUED CHAO YOU MAY
OPEN. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
MISTER SPEAKER MEMBERS EIGHTY
NINE OH FOUR SEEKS TO ENSURE
THAT GOVERNMENT ENTITIES CANNOT
USE TRACKING SOFTWARE TO TRACK
THE MOVEMENT OF THE PERSON OR
OBJECT WITHOUT A WARRANT.
CURRENT LAW REQUIRES A SEARCH
WARRANT TO BE ISSUE PRIOR TO AN
OFFICER INSTALLING A TRACKING
DEVICE WAS SERVING A WARRANT ON
A THIRD PARTY POSSESS THEIR OF
THE TRACKING DATA. HOWEVER WITH
ADVANCES TECHNOLOGY IT IT IS NO
LONGER NECESSARY FOR AN OFFICER
TO MAKE PHYSICAL CONTACT WITH
THE DEVICE. PERSONAL VEHICLE TO
INSTALL THE DEVICE BUT IT
ATTRACT IN INDIVIDUAL NOWADAYS
THE GOVERNMENT OF SOUL IT'S
ONLY TO HELP WIRELESS ACCESS TO
HELLO TRACKING SOFTWARE THAT
WILL PROVIDE INVESTIGATORS WITH
TO MEET. THE NEEDS. SINCE
CURRENT LAW DOES NOT EXPLICITLY.
TO BE A MECHANICAL DEVICE SO AB
NINE OH FOUR WOULD CLARIFY THAT
A TRACKING DEVICE INCLUDES ANY
SOFTWARE THAT PERMITS THE
TRACKING OF THE MOVEMENT OF A
PERSON. OR OBJECT FOR PURPOSES
OF THE STATUE WITHOUT I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AYE VOTE.
I THINK HIS. NAME IS CHAO
SEEING NO DISCUSSION DEBATE ON
THE ITEM. CLICK LIBERAL. VOTE
DESIRE TO VOTE. ALL MEMBERS
VOTERS OUT OF A. ALL MEMBERS
VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE. CLARK
WELL. CLOSE ROLL TIDE ABOUT I
SIXTY NINE NO ZERO THAT MEASURE
PASSES FILE ITEM THIRTY ONE
PASS RETAIN WE'VE DISPENSED
WITH FILE ITEM THIRTY TWO. WE
ARE AT FILE ITEM THIRTY THREE.
AB SIXTY SIX BY MISS GONZALEZ
CORPORATE SOME PEOPLE SIXTY SIX
BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER GONZALEZ AND
OTHERS AND ACTUALLY TO TAXATION
TO TAKE EFFECT IMMEDIATELY TAX
LEVY. MS GONZALEZ FEMALE BUT
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER AS OF
JANUARY FIRST OF THIS YEAR
DIAPERS ARE FINALLY TAX FREE IN
CALIFORNIA JOINING THE EIGHT
OTHER STATES THAT HAVE TAX FREE
DIAPERS BUT UNFORTUNATELY THAT
WILL. SUNSET ACCORDING TO THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET IN TWENTY
TWENTY THREE. IT SHOULD BE
OBVIOUS THAT THEY SHOULD HAVE
NO SUNSET UNFORTUNATELY THIS
BILL DOES BUT AT LEAST EXTENDS
IT TO TWENTY TWENTY SEVEN I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE TO VOTE AGAINST THE DIAPER
TAX. THANK YOU MS GONZALEZ.
SEEING NO DISCUSSION OR DEBATE
ON THE ITEM. CLICK LIBERAL ON
MEMBERS OF. IT IS OUT OF OUT
ALL MEMBERS VOTE THE DESIRE TO
VOTE. ALL MEMBERS VOTERS OUT OF
OUT. CLICK WELL CLOSE ROLL TIDE
ABOUT I SEVENTY. NO ZERO THAT
MEASURE PASSES FILE ITEM THIRTY
FOUR AB SEVENTY CORPORATION
ASSEMBLY BILL SEVENTY BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER BERMAN AND
OTHERS AND ACTUALLY TO PRIVATE
POSTSECONDARY EDUCATION. MR
BERMAN YOU MAY OPEN THANK YOU
MISTER SPEAKER AND COLLEAGUES
AB SEVENTY IS SIMILAR TO
LEGISLATION I INTRODUCED LAST
YEAR WHICH RECEIVE NO NO VOTES
ON THE FLOOR AB SEVENTY WOULD
PREVENT FOR PROFIT COLLEGES
FROM COVERTLY EVADING STATE
OVERSIGHT BY REQUIRING THE
ATTORNEY GENERAL TO DETERMINE
WHETHER AN INSTITUTION. THAT
CLAIMS TO BE A NONPROFIT
COLLEGE OR A PUBLIC COLLEGE
ACTUALLY MEETS THE DEFINITION
OF A NONPROFIT CORPORATION OR
PUBLIC INSTITUTION OF HIGHER
EDUCATION THROUGH AB SEVENTY
CALIFORNIA WHAT'S THE PROTECT
OUR STUDENTS FROM THESE FOR
PROFIT BECAUSE IT IS. THAT
TRYING TO IN THE STEM AND IS
SHORT. RED OVERSIGHT REMAINS
OUR RESPECT ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE.
THERE WAS BERMAN. SEE NO
DISCUSSION DEBATE. CAR CLUB THE
ROLE. IT IS OUT OF OUT ALL
MEMBERS THAT IT IS OUT OF A-
ALL MEMBERS VOTED ASIDE ABOUT.
CLARK WELL CULTURAL TIE THAT I
SEVENTY ONE NO ZERO THAT
MEASURE PASSES FILE ITEM THIRTY
FIVE PASS RETAIN FILE ITEM
THIRTY SIX AB TWO ONE SIX.
CALGARY ASSEMBLY BILL TWO
SIXTEEN BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
WEBER AND ACTUALLY TO SCHOOL
SAFETY DOCTOR WEBER YOU MAY
OPEN YES MISTER SPEAKER AND
MEMBERS I RISE TODAY WITH GREAT
PLEASURE IN PRESENTING AB TWO
SIXTEEN WHICH ESTABLISHED THAT
THE PEOPLE IN SAFETY. STAFF
SAFETY PILOT PROGRAM TO PROVIDE
SCHOOL STAFF TRAINING ON
ALTERNATIVES TO PHYSICAL
RESTRAINT AND SECLUSION OF
STUDENTS AND ON DE ESCALATION
TECHNIQUES. TOO OFTEN STUDENTS
WITH SIGNIFICANT DISABILITIES
SUCH AS AUTISM ANY MOST OF THE
SERVANTS ARE PLACED INTO
DANGEROUS IN AN APPROPRIATE
RESTRAINTS AND SECLUSION
THROUGHOUT CALIFORNIA.
CURRENTLY TWELVE DAYS IN
SECLUSION OF ALL STUDENTS WELL
EIGHTEEN DO SO FOR STUDENTS
WITH DISABILITIES ALONE
NINETEEN STATES PROTECT ALL
STUDENTS LIMIT THE USE OF
FRAMES TO. SAYS OF IMMEDIATE.
VISIBLE DATE. CALIFORNIA'S FALL
BEHIND FEDERAL GOT AND- ADOPTED
BY OTHER STATES TO REDUCE THE
USE OF THESE DANGERS PRACTICES
AND INSTEAD IMPLEMENT POSITIVE
BEHAVIORAL TECHNIQUES. AS A
PART OF STATEWIDE EFFORTS TO
RESTRICT THE USE OF RESTRAINT
AND SECLUSION ALONG WITH BUT A
NEW SOME COMMITMENT TO
PROVIDING SAFER AND MORE
INCLUSIVE CLASSROOMS.
CALIFORNIA SCHOOL STAFF NEEDS
TO PROPERLY. TRAIN ON DE
ESCALATION TECHNIQUES TO
ACHIEVE THESE GOALS. THIS BILL
PROVIDES TRAINING FOR THESE
SITUATIONS WITH UP WILL HELP
PREVENT SITUATIONS AS A WEAPON
IN EL DORADO COUNTY AND
COUNTLESS OTHERS ACROSS THE
STATE. AB TWO SIXTEEN
ESTABLISHED THE PUPIL IN SPOT
AND STAFF STEVE PILOT PROGRAM
ADMINISTERED BY EXISTING SCALE
UP YEAH YES IT STATE WHAT.
PROJECT IN CONSULTATION WITH
THE TWENTY DEPARTMENT OF
EDUCATION. THIS PROGRAM WILL
AWARD GOES TO LOCAL EDUCATIONAL
AGENCY FOR THE PURPOSE OF
TRAINING SCHOOL STAFF- TURN IT
IS TO SECLUSION AND RESTRAINT
AND STAY FOR DE ESCALATE TO X.
THIS BILL SPONSORED BY
DISABILITY RIGHT CALIFORNIA.
AND IS SUPPORTED BY THE
ALLIANCE OF BOYS AND MEN OF
COLOR. IT SHOULDN'T HAVE AN UP
IN ARMS ASK FOR YOUR THOSE BE.
TO SIXTEEN. THEY YOU DOCTOR
WEBER. SEC IT IS VERY ON THE-
CLICK LIBERAL MEMBERS. IT IS
OUT OF OUT ALL MEMBERS OTHERS
ARE OF ALL. ALL MEMBERS VOTERS
ABOUT. CLARK WELL CLOSER ALL
TITLE BUT I SIXTY FIVE NO ZERO.
THAT MEASURE PASSES FILE ITEM
THIRTY SEVEN PASSED RETAIN FILE
ITEM THIRTY EIGHT. AB TWO SEVEN
SIX CORPORATION ASSEMBLY BILL
TWO SEVENTY SIX BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER FRIEDMAN AND ACT
PEOPLE SAFETY MISS FRIEDMAN.
THANK YOU SPEAKER MEMBERS AB
TWO SEVENTY SIX IS A POLICY
DESIGNED TO INFORM PARENTS AND
ENSURE THAT CHILDREN ARE KEPT
SAFE AND AWAY FROM UNSAFE FIRE
ARMS STORAGE. THE FACTS ABOUT
UNSAFE FIREARMS STORAGE IT
CANNOT BE IGNORED OR SOME OF
THE MOST TRAGIC STATISTICS THAT
WE HAVE IN THE STATE FOUR POINT
SIX MILLION CHILDREN I DID
STATES HOMES WITH ACCESS TO AN
UNLOCKED OR UNSERVED. DONE 75%
OF YOUR IN WITH A GUN IS STORED
IN THEIR HOME ONE OUT OF FIVE
PARENTS DIDN'T KNOW THAT THEIR
CHILD TO HANDLE GOT SUPER AND
THINK ABOUT THAT MEANS. THAT
MEANS TO YOU THE ONE FIVE
CHANCE OF YOUR CHILD HAVE
HANDLED OR SEE FIREARM
ASSIDUOUS THAT YOU PROBABLY
KNOW NOTHING ABOUT. SEVEN
SHOOTING BY HAVING ACT TO AND
IN ON GUNS AND HOW AND THE
STATISTICS OF HERE DON'T LIST
THE NUMBER OF TEEN SUICIDES
THAT OCCUR BECAUSE TEENAGERS
WERE ABLE TO GET THEIR HANDS ON
A GUN THAT'S IN THEIR OWN HOME
HAD A SUCH A SUICIDE IN MY
STORY TO ONLY TWO MONTHS AGO
AND ANOTHER ONE JUST LAST YEAR.
THAT WOULD REQUIRE THAT A NOTE.
TO BE SAID PARENTS TO ENSURE
THAT THEIR FAMILY KNOWS WHEN
WHERE AND HOW A FIRE ARM NEEDS
TO SAFELY BE STORED WHAT
TECHNIQUES WORK AND WHAT
TECHNIQUES DON'T AND ALSO TO
GIVE THEM. THE INFORMATION
ABOUT HOW DANGEROUS. MIGHT BE
IN THEIR OWN HOME. NEED TOOLS
TO NAVIGATE CALIFORNIA SAFE
FIREARM STORAGE LAWS IN ORDER
TO KEEP THEIR OWN CHILDREN AND
ALL OF OUR CHILDREN SAFE. A TWO
SEVENTY SIX FACILITATES
EDUCATION BY REQUIRING THE
DEPARTMENT OF EDUCATION IN
CONSULTATION WITH THE
DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE. TO
PRODUCE A NOTIFICATION THAT
WILL ANNUALLY BE SENT HOME TO
PARENTS. SAVE STORAGE SAVES
LIVES LET'S MAKE SURE THAT
PARENTS HAVE ALL THE TOOLS THEY
NEED TO KEEP KIDS SAFE THIS
BILL PASSED OUT OF COMMITTEE
WITH UNANIMOUS BIPARTISAN
SUPPORT. AND I REQUEST DR TODAY
THANK YOU. THANK YOU MS
FRIEDMAN. SEE NO DISCUSSION
DEBATE ON THIS ITEM. CLICK
LIBERAL. IT IS OUT OF OUT ALL
MEMBERS VOTERS ART OF THE. ALL
MEMBERS OUT THE DESIRE TO VOTE.
CLICK WELL CLOSER ALL THE TIME
ABOUT AYE AYES SIXTY FOUR NO
ZERO. THAT MEASURE PASSES. FILE
ITEM THIRTY NINE. AB FOR SIXTY
FOUR COVERING ASSEMBLY BILL
FOUR SIXTY FOUR BY FAMILY
MEMBER CRISTINA GARCIA AND
OTHERS AND ACTUALLY THE
GREENHOUSE GASES MS GARCIA.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER
MEMBERS AB FOR SIXTY FOUR
FIFTHS OF BY THE CONTRIBUTION
FROM NATURAL SOURCES OF AIR
POLLUTION. INCLUDING THE AIR
RESOURCE BOARD ARE POLLUTION
AND THEN TORY MUST INCLUDE
CATASTROPHIC WILDFIRES. THERE'S
A NEED TO ACCOUNT FOR AI
POLLUTANTS RESULTING FROM
CATASTROPHIC WILDFIRES AT THE
STATE HAS EXPERIENCED IN MORE
RECENT YEARS I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR AN AYE VOTE. THANK YOU MISS
GARCIA. SEEING THEIR DISCRETION
BAIT. OR CALL THE ROLL CALL
MEMBERS. IS OUT OF OUT ALL
MEMBERS VOTED IS OUT OF OUT.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE.
YEAH. CLARK WELL. CLOSER ALL
TIE BUT I SIXTY NINE OH ZERO.
THAT MEASURE PASSES FILE ITEM.
FORTY EIGHTY FOUR NINETY NINE
BY MISTER MAYES. CORPORATION
ASSEMBLY BILL FOUR NINETY NINE
BY SOME THE MEMBER MAYES AND
ACTUALLY THE STATE GOVERNMENT
MR MAYES YOU MAY OPEN THANK YOU
MISTER SPEAKER. AND MEMBERS I
RISE TODAY TO PRESENT EIGHTY
FOUR NINE NINE ACCORDING THE
CALIFORNIA STATE AUDITOR SINCE
THE TWENTY SEVENTEEN EIGHTEEN
FISCAL YEAR THE EMPLOYMENT
DEVELOPMENT DEPARTMENT HAS SENT
MORE THAN SEVENTEEN MILLION
PIECES OF MAIL CONTAINING FULL
SO SECURITY NUMBERS
UNNECESSARILY EXPOSING
CALIFORNIA'S IDENTIFY IDENTITY
THEFT. EDT USES SO SECURE
NUMBERS AS AN IDENTIFIER FOR
INDIVIDUALS APPLYING FOR
UNEMPLOYMENT DISABILITY OR PAID
FAMILY LEAVE BENEFITS HOWEVER
USE OF SO SECURING NUMBERS IS
NOT REQUIRED NEEDED WHICH IS
WHY ET DE IS CURRENTLY
UNDERGOING A SYSTEM OF
MODERNIZATION. WILL PULL
INCORPORATING IDENTIFIER TO
REPLACE SO MANY NUMBERS. I MEAN
THIS THIS THEM MODERNIZATION
ONE TOPIC UNTIL TO TWENTY. EDT
WHY SEND APPROXIMATELY SEVENTY
MILLION DOCUMENTS WAS SO
SECURITY NUMBERS DURING THIS
PERIOD. THIS BODIES CONTINUALLY
TAKEN STEPS TO PROTECT
CALIFORNIA FROM IDENTITY THEFT.
AND EIGHTY FOUR NINE NINE IS
THE NEXT STEP. THIS LEGISLATION
INCORPORATE STATE AUDITOR
RECOMMENDATIONS BY PROHIBITING
THE MAILING OF SO SECURE NEW
NUMBERS UNLESS REQUIRED BY
FEDERAL LAW. REQUIRING AGENCIES
REPORT BACK ON THEIR USE OF SO
SECURING NUMBERS AND PROVIDING
APPROPRIATE IDENTITY THEFT
PREVENTION AND MITIGATION TO
AFFECTED INDIVIDUALS. WITHOUT
THIS LEGISLATION SO SECURE
NUMBERS WILL NOT BE PROTECTED
IN CALIFORNIA. ET RECENTLY SAID
AGENCY WILL NOT IMPLEMENT. THIS
STATE AUDITOR'S RECOMMENDATION
I RESPECTFULLY REQUEST ARRIVE A.
THERE WAS A MESS. SENIOR
DISCLOSURE BATES CAR CLUB THERE
ALL MEMBERS VOTE. DESIRED BUT
ALL MEMBERS OF OUR DESIRE TO
VOTE. ALL MEMBERS OTHERS ADDED
VOTE. CLICK WELL CLOSE ROLL
TIDE BUT I SIXTY SEVEN NO ZERO
THAT MEASURE PASSES. FILE ITEM
FORTY ONE A. B. FIVE FIVE NINE
COOKERY ASSEMBLY BILL FIVE
FIFTY NINE BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
ARAMULA AND ACTUALLY THE STATE
PARKS DOCTOR REGULAR. THANK YOU
MISTER SPEAKER AND MEMBERS
TODAY I PRESENT ON AB FIVE FIVE
NINE IN NINETEEN NINETY TWO THE
LEGISLATURE CREATED THE SAN
JOAQUIN RIVER CONSERVANCY TO
DEVELOP AND MANAGE THE SAN
JOAQUIN RIVER PARKWAY. HOWEVER
TWENTY EIGHT YEARS LATER MUCH
WORK YET REMAINS IN ORDER TO
FULLY OPERATE AND MANAGE THE
PARKWAY. THIS IS THE REALITY IN
A PART OF OUR STATE THAT IS
SEVERELY UNDER SERVED AND
CONTINUES TO FALL BEHIND IN THE
RATES OF PARKS PER CAPITA. AB
FIVE FIVE NINE WILL HELP TO
PROVIDE HEALTHY RECREATIONAL
OPPORTUNITIES TO A PART OF OUR
STATE THAT IS SEVERELY LACKING
GREEN SPACE. THIS BILL WILL
ALLOW THE SAN JOAQUIN RIVER
CONSERVANCY TO ENTER INTO A
MANAGEMENT AGREEMENT WITH THE
STATE PARKS THAT WOULD PROVIDE
FOR OPERATIONS AND ENDS OF THE
TRAIL INSPECTORS THAT THE
PARKWAY HAS ACQUIRED. MEMBERS I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU DOCTOR RAY
MILLAND SEEN NO DISCUSSION
DEBATE. OUR GLOBAL ROLE MEMBERS.
THE DESIRE TO VOTE ALL MEMBERS
OTHERS OUT OF A. ALL MEMBERS
VOTERS ARE TO VOTE. CLICK WELL.
CLOSE ROLL TIDE ABOUT AYE SIXTY
FIVE NO ZERO THAT MEASURE
PASSES FILE ITEM FORTY TWO AB
FIVE EIGHTY TWO COVERAGE
ASSEMBLY BILL FIVE EIGHTY TWO
BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER EDUARDO
GARCIA AND OTHERS AND ACTUALLY
THE VEHICLES MR GARCIA TO
SPEAKER AND COLLEAGUES. SB FIVE
EIGHTY TWO IS A BILL NAMED IN
HONOR OF TWO INDIVIDUALS WHO
WERE TRAGICALLY KILLED IN
SEPARATE HIT AND RUNS HERE IN
CALIFORNIA THE FIRST. AVERY
GLOVER AN ELEVEN YEAR OLD CHILD
WHO WAS KILLED IN A FATAL HIT
AND RUN ACCIDENT NO CENTRAL
CALIFORNIA AND THE SECOND GAVIN
GLADDING A BELOVED CLOVIS
UNIFIED SCHOOL DISTRICT VICE
PRINCIPAL WAS TRAGICALLY KILLED
IN A HIT AND RUN ACCIDENT TWO
THOUSAND EIGHTEEN. THIS BILL
BRINGS THE CODE IN LINE WITH
OTHER PENALTIES THAT ARE
ASSESSED. FOR VEHICULAR
MANSLAUGHTER AND MAKING THEM
GREATER THAN A D. Y. SENTENCE
WHEN THERE IS A DEATH. IN THE
CIRCUMSTANCE. AB FIVE EIGHTY
TWO WILL HOPEFULLY ENCOURAGE
DRIVERS. TO STAY AT THE SCENE
OF THE CRIME. FOR THE PURPOSE
OF ONE. HOPEFULLY RENDERING AID
TO. THE INJURED VICTIM. AND TO.
TO PRESERVE THE INTEGRITY OF
EVIDENCE ON THE SCENE. AND FOR
THE PURPOSE OF ASSESSING
WHETHER OR NOT. CHARGES SHOULD
BE IMPOSED. AND TO BRING ABOUT
JUSTICE. FOR A VICTIM AND THEIR
FAMILY. SPECTRUM OUT. YOUR AYE
VOTE ON A. B. TO ENSURE THAT
THAT THAT COMPASSION AND- YOU
KNOW WHEN ACCIDENTS HAPPEN THAT
IT BE DETERMINED IT WAS AN
ACCIDENT BUT IF IT WAS
SOMETHING THAT COULD HAVE BEEN
PREVENTED THAT PEOPLE BE HELD
ACCOUNTABLE AND RESPONSIBLE FOR
THEIR ACTIONS RESPECT. YES FOR
A VOTE. THANK YOU MISTER
SIMMONS PATTERSON YOUR
RECOGNIZED THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER AND- MEMBERS AS A-
JOINT AUTHOR OF THE GAVIN'S LAW
A. B. FIVE EIGHTY TWO I RISE TO
ASK FOR YOUR SUPPORT. I ALSO
WANT TO EXTEND MY APPRECIATION
AND BANKS ON BEHALF OF THE-
LEADING FAMILY AS WELL AS THOSE
OF US WHO HAVE BEEN WORKING ON
THE BILL. FOR THE EFFORT IN
GETTING IT HERE AND WE REALLY
APPRECIATED VERY MUCH
PARTICULARLY TO. MY COLLEAGUE
FROM THE COACHELLA VALLEY FOR
LEADING THIS EFFORT. OF THE
DRIVER. WHO KILLED GAVIN
PLOTTING A BELOVED VICE
PRINCIPAL FROM CLOVIS OF.
DIDN'T STOP. DIDN'T HELP AS
GAVIN LAY THERE CLINGING TO
LIFE HE FLED THE SCENE.
EVIDENCE FOUND THAT THIS DRIVER
WAS DRINKING AT A PARTY- JUST
HOURS BEFORE THE HIT AND RUN.
BECAUSE HE FLED THE SCENE AND
WAS NOT CAUGHT UNTIL FIVE DAYS
LATER LAW ENFORCEMENT OFFICIALS
COULDN'T PROVE THAT HE WAS
DROPPING UNDER THE INFLUENCE
AND HE SERVED ONLY ONE YEAR. SO
THIS AS THE MEMBER FROM
COACHELLA VALLEY STATED THERE
IS THIS PERVERSE LOOPHOLE IN
THE LAW WHICH ENCOURAGES
DRIVERS UNDER THE INFLUENCE TO
FLEE. A BY FLEEING THEY CAN
AVOID ADDITIONAL CHARGES AB
FIVE EIGHTY TWO WILL INCREASE
THE PENALTIES FOR LEAVING THE
SCENE OF AN ACCIDENT WHICH
RESULTS IN DEATH. AND HOPEFULLY
WILL REDUCE THE INCENTIVE TO
HIP KILL AND THEN LEAVE THE
SAME. GAVIN LIVED HIS LIFE FOR
OTHERS. HE CONTINUES TO DO
THROW DO SO IN IN SPIRIT
THROUGH THIS BILL. BY CLOSING
THIS CURRENT LOOPHOLE WE HOPE
THAT. WE WILL PREVENT FUTURE
TRAGEDIES OF THIS NATURE WE
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE THANK YOU MEMBERS. HE WAS
PATTERSON MISTER GIBSON YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED THANK YOU VERY MUCH
FOR SPEAKER MEMBERS I DON'T
NEED TO- ASKS OR REGURGITATES-
WITH THE HISTORY OF HIT AND
RUN- YOU KNOW COLLEAGUES THAT
THIS AFFECTS ME PERSONALLY-
BECAUSE THE WOMAN- STILL AT
LARGE IT HAS BEEN A LARGE. UP
FOR MANY MANY YEARS- THIS IS
RIGHT WHAT- AN INDIVIDUAL WE
JUST BEAR A DEPUTY SHERIFF
OFFICERS LOS ANGELES COUNTY-
THE STORIES LOW DIFFERENCE
BECAUSE THE PERSON SHE WAS
TRYING TO HELP ACROSS THE
STREET. THE PERSON SHE WAS
HELPING ACROSS THE STREET THIS
DEPUTY GOT OVER CAR TO HELP. A
PERSON ACROSS THE STREET AND AS
SHE WAS GOING BACK TO HER
POLICE CAR HER LIFE WAS TAKEN.
THE STORY IS DIFFERENT BECAUSE
THAT INDIVIDUAL STATE AND
pAGAIN WE HEAR STORIES ON
TELEVISION AND RADIO THAT A
PERSON WAS KILLED IN A
CROSSWALK AND THE PERSON IS
STILL AT LARGE OR AT LEAST. DO
THIS TO ESCAPE FROM STANDING UP
FOR WHAT THEY'VE DONE AND SO
THIS BILL HELPS FAMILIES TO
CLOSE NOT ONLY CLOSER WHEN OF
INDIVIDUAL A LOVED ONE HAS LOST
A LIFE TO IT HIT AND RUN
ACCIDENT- BUT ALSO CLIPS OF THE
LAW. THE STILLER PULL IN OURS
LAW THE GOOD BILL I WANT TO
THANK THE MEMBER FROM COACHELLA
AND ALSO THE MEMBER WHO ACT AS
A CO AUTHOR THIS BILL THANK YOU
MUCH OF THE GOOD OKAY CERTAINLY
ASK. VOTE. THANK YOU MISTER
GIVES. SEEING NO OTHER MEMBERS
SEEKING RECOGNITION ON THE ITEM
MISTER GARCIA WOULD YOU LIKE TO
CLOSE. MEMBERS WE ARE HAVING AN
ISSUE WITH THE VOTING
MECHANISM. AT THE DESKS WHAT
WE'RE GOING TO DO IT THIS TIME
IS REBOOT THE VOTING SYSTEM.
FOR LACK OF A BETTER TERM. AND
THEN- WE WILL INDICATE TO YOU
WHEN THE ROLE IS GOING TO BE
OPENED SO WE'RE GOING TO PAUSE.
BRIEFLY WHILE WE REBOOT THE
VOTING SYSTEM. WILL BE WITH YOU
MOMENTARILY.
MEMBERS WE'VE BEEN
GIVEN THE GREEN LIGHT ON THE
GREEN BUTTON. WE MEMBERS I GET
HAVE ATTENTION. MEMBERS WE ARE
A FILE ITEM FORTY TWO AB FIVE
EIGHTY TWO MISTER GARCIA IS
CLOSED. THE SYSTEM IS BACK UP.
THE CLERK. WELL OPEN THE ROLE
ALL MEMBERS OF. WHO DESIRED
ABOUT. ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE
TO VOTE. ALL MEMBERS VOTE. THE
DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS
VOTERS OUT OF THE CLERK WILL.
CLOSE ROLL TIDE ABOUT I SIXTY
THREE. KNOWS THREE. THAT
MEASURE PASSES. FILE ITEMS
FORTY THREE AND FORTY FOUR.
PAST RETAIN. WE ARE AT FILE
ITEM. FORTY FIVE AB SIX NINE
NINE BY MISTER GRACE IN THE
CORPORATE ASSEMBLY BILL SIX
NINETY NINE BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
GRAYSON AND EXPLAIN TO CONSUMER
CREDIT RESTORATION THANK YOU
MISTER SPEAKER COLLEAGUES TODAY
I RISE TO PRESENT AB SIX NINETY
NINE TO BRING MUCH NEEDED
TRANSPARENCY TO CREDIT SERVICE
ORGANIZATIONS ALSO CALLED CS-
SO RATING RIGHT HERE IN
CALIFORNIA SEE ESOS FOR
ORGANIZATIONS THAT OFFER TO
REPAIR A CONSUMERS CREDIT FILE.
EXCHANGE FOR PAYMENT TYPICAL
SERVICES INCLUDE SCORE ANALYSIS
BUREAU CHALLENGES CREDITOR
INTERVENTIONS HOWEVER THE
SERVICES OFTEN LACK CLEAR
DISCLOSURES OF WHAT SPECIFIC
SERVICES A CONSUMER IS
PURCHASING AND EQUALLY
IMPORTANT DISCLOSURES ON WHAT
SCO SO HAS ACTUALLY DONE ON
BEHALF OF A CLIENT. AB SIX
NINETY AND PROTECTS CONSUMERS
BY REQUIRING ITEMIZE MONTHLY
STATEMENTS OF SERVICES
PERFORMED CLEAR DISCLOSURES OF
WHAT NEGATIVE CREDIT
INFORMATION TO SEE ALSO WILL
CHALLENGE AND IT THIS IS THE
ABOUT IS JUST SO BE JOBS TO
FORM THIS STATE LAW OVER THE
LAST YEAR I HAVE WORKED WITH
COMMITTEES. WAS SUPPORTERS AND
OPPOSITE TO STRIKE A REASONABLE
BALANCE BETWEEN CONSUMER
PROTECTION AND ENSURING THAT
LEGITIMATE CSOS CAN CONTINUE
THEIR WORK DUE TO AN ISSUE
AROUND FEDERAL AND STATE LAW
THAT WAS RECENTLY RAISED AND
PRIVACY AND CONSUMER PROTECTION
COMMITTEE HAVE MADE COMMITMENTS
TO FURTHER AMEND THIS BILL AND
THIS. THIS BILL HAS BY. AND
WITH THAT I WAS ASK FOR YOUR-
THANK YOU MISS GRAYSON. SENIOR
DISCUSSION MADE ON THE ITEM
LOCAL OF THE ROLE MEMBERS OF.
RESERVE AT ALL MEMBERS VOTERS
ABOUT ON MEMBERS VOTERS TO VOTE.
CLARK WELL. CLOSER ALL TIES BUT
I FIFTY SEVEN NO ZERO THAT
MEASURE PASSES FILE ITEM FORTY
SIX PASS RETAIN. FILE ITEM.
MISTER CALDERON YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED FOR MOTION THANK YOU
MISTER SPEAKER AT THE REQUEST
OF THE AUTHOR I AM GIVING A ONE
DAY NOTICE TO REMOVE I TO ME
TOO AB ELEVEN NINETY SIX GIPSON
FROM THE INACTIVE FILE. THE
CLERK WILL. I MOVE TO SUSPEND
ASSEMBLY RULE SIXTY THREE TO
ALLOW AUTHORS TO TAKE UP THEIR
BILLS ON THE SECOND READING
FATHER DAY FOR THE PURPOSE OF
THIRD READING FLOOR FOR PURPOSE
YOUR ANSWER. THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER WE WITHHOLD UNANIMOUS
CONSENT AND ASK FOR A ROLL CALL
VOTE. IN THIS CASE MISTER
CALDERON MOVES AND MR BONTA
SECONDS THAT THE RULES BE
SUSPENDED MEMBERS AS THEY
PROCEDURAL VOTE. CAR CLUB IN
THE WRONG. CALDERON IS ASKED
FOR AN AYE VOTE. MISTER FLORA
AND NO. MISTER CALDERON TASK
FOR AN AYE VOTE MISTER FLOORS
ASKING FOR A NO VOTE. ON THE
SUSPENSION OF THE RULES. CLARK
WELL. CLOSE ROLL TIDE BUT I'D
FIFTY TWO KNOWS SEVENTEEN.
MOTION CARRIES. BACK ON THE
THIRD READING FIVE MEMBERS FILE
ITEM. FORTY SIX WE PASS RETAIN
WHERE FILE ITEM FORTY SEVEN
EIGHTY NINE OH EIGHT BY MR
O'DONNELL THE CLERK READ. AS
ONLY ONE NINE OH EIGHT BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER O'DONNELL
CONNECTING PEOPLE SETTLEMENT MR
O'DONNELL THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER AND MEMBERS AB NIGHT OR
IT WILL GIVE TEACHERS ACCESS TO
RETIRE TEST ITEMS FROM THE
STATE IT WAS PRINCE OF ENGLISH
LANGUAGE ARTS. MADAM MADAM FOR
USE A FORMATIVE ASSESSMENT TOOL
IN THE CLASSROOM. CALIFORNIA
SCHOOL TEACHERS CURRENTLY HAVE
ACCESS TO SOME SAMPLE TEST
ITEMS BUT THEY ARE LIMITED IN
NUMBER NOT ORGANIZED BY
STANDARD AND CONTAINED FEW
PERFORMANCE TASKS. MANY OTHER
STATES AS WELL THE AS WELL AS
THE OTHER NATIONAL ASSESSMENT-CONSORTIUM PROVIDE EXTENSIVE
COLLECTIONS OF RELEASED TEST
ITEMS AS WELL AS SCORING GUIDES
AND SAMPLES OF STUDENT WORK.
CALIFORNIA TEACHER SHOULD HAVE
THE SAME KIND OF RESOURCES TO
SUPPORT AND ASSESS STUDENT
LEARNING. I ASKED FOR AN AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU MISTER
O'DONNELL SENIOR DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE. OR CALL THE ROLL ALL
MEMBERS OF. SORRY ALL MEMBERS
VOTERS ARE TO VOTE. ALL MEMBERS
VOTERS ARE TO VOTE. CLARK WELL.
THE CLOTHES ARE ALL TIED WHAT I
SIXTY SEVEN NO ZERO THAT
MEASURE PASSES FILE ITEM FORTY
EIGHT IS AB NINE SEVENTY NINE
CORPORATION AS A LEGAL NINE
SEVENTY NINE BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER
REYES AND EXPLAIN TO THE PUBLIC
RETIREMENT SYSTEMS MS REYES
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER
NUMBERS AB NINE SEVENTY NINE
PLACES BACK INTO LAW REQUIRED
ANNUAL REPORTS TO THE
LEGISLATURE REGARDING CALPERS
AND CAL STIRS USE OF EMERGING
MANAGERS FOR PURPOSES OF ASSET
MANAGEMENT I RISK THE ASPIRIN.
THANK REYES SURVEYS ARE THE RAW.
MEMBERS OF. HIS OUT OF ALL
MEMBERS ARE TO VOTE. ALL
MEMBERS VOTERS OUT OF A. CLARK
WELL. CLOSE ROLL TIDE BUT I
SIXTY NO ZERO THAT MEASURE
PASSES FILE ITEM FORTY NINE IS
AB TEN SEVENTY ONE CLERK READ
AS ON THE BILL TEN SEVENTY ONE
BY SOME REMEMBER LOW MOAN AND
OTHERS AND EXPLAIN TO CLIMATE
CHANGE MS LAMONT THANK YOU
MISTER SPEAKER AB TEN SEVENTY
ONE ESTABLISHES A COMPETITIVE
GRANT PROGRAM TO HELP
AGRICULTURE IN CALIFORNIA ADAPT
TO CLIMATE CHANGE THIS PROGRAM
WILL DIVIDE UP CLIMATE
ADAPTATION RESEARCH IS AND
TRAININGS TO HELP FARMERS IN
RIGHT. PLAN AND IT FOR CLIMATE
CHANGE. AB IF ANYONE HAS NO I.
AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN
AYE VOTE. FAMOUS AMONG SEE NO
DISCUSSION OF A CLERK WILL OVER
THERE ALL. MEMBERS OTHERS OUT
ABOUT ALL MEMBERS VOTERS OUT OF
A- ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO
VOTE. YEAH CLARK WELL. CLOSER
ALL TELL YOU ABOUT. I SIXTY NO
ZERO THAT MEASURE PASSES FILE
ITEM FIFTY IS AB ELEVEN FORTY
FIVE CLICK READ ASSEMBLY BILL
ELEVEN FORTY FIVE BUY SOMETHING
MEMBER CRISTINA GARCIA ACTUALLY
THE CRIMES IS GARCIA THANK YOU
AB ELEVEN FORTY FIVE THIS
SPONSORED BY A QUALITY
CALIFORNIA IS SIMPLY STATE
MANDATED REPORTER MISTER ALL
TEENAGERS THE SAME ON AND IT
HAS NO OPPOSITION ARTISTICALLY
ASPIRIN I WROTE. THANK YOU
MISTER SEQUENCING CASH DEBATE
CLERK WILL OF THE ROLE.
OBSERVER ALL MEMBERS OTHERS ARE
TO VOTE. ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE
TO VOTE. YEAH. ALL MEMBERS ARE
DESERT ABOUT. THE CLERK WILL.
CLOSER ALL TIED ABOUT ICE FORTY
ONE NO SEVENTEEN. THAT MEASURE
PASSES FILE ITEM FIFTY ONE PASS
RETAIN. FILE ITEM FIFTY TWO AB
THIRTEEN FIFTY I MISS GONZALES.
THE CLERK WILL READ AT SOME
LEVEL THIRTEEN FIFTY BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER GOING OFF
GONZALEZ AND OTHERS ACTUALLY
TRANSPORTATION IS GOOD SALAS
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER
ASSEMBLY BILL THIRTEEN FIFTY
OLD FURTHER CALIFORNIA'S
CLIMATE CHANGE EMISSIONS
REDUCTION GOALS BY INCREASING
YOU ACCESS TO PUBLIC TRANSIT
SPECIFICALLY THIS WILL REQUIRE
LOCAL TRANSIT AGENCIES TO OFFER
FREE TRANSIT PASSES TO ALL
CALIFORNIANS AGE EIGHT AND
UNDER REGARDLESS OF INCOME OR
EDUCATIONAL STATUS I AM MATED
WORKING IN THE SENATE ON THE
WAYS IN WHICH WE USE. ARAFAT
HELP PROGRAM FOR LOCAL THAT
EIGHT SEIZE THE DON'T HAVE THE
RESOURCES TO DO THAT THAT I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR MY ABOUT.
THANK YOU MS GONZALEZ FLETCHER
GIPSON YOUR RECOGNIZE THANK YOU
MUCH MRS MA'AM I RISE IN
SUPPORT. OF ASSEMBLY BILL
THIRTEEN FIFTY- THIS WALL THIS
BILL WILL CREATE A GENERATION
CALIFORNIA'S THAT WILL BECOME
LIFELONG TRANSIT USERS- BY
ASKING A TRANSIT AGENCY TO
PRIVATE PRIORITIZE- YOUTH
RIDERSHIP. THAT THIS BILL WILL-
ALLOW INDIVIDUALS- YOUNG PEOPLE
TO BE OF A RIDE- TRANSLATION
FREE IT CREATES A NEW
GENERATION OF INDIVIDUALS
THEY'LL BE VERY VERY SUPPORT.
OF OUR PUBLIC TRANSPORT TAKE
HIS OF AND SO YOU THE MY
DISTRICT IS REMOVED ANOTHER
VERY BECAUSE A LOT OF YOU HAVE
GET TO AND FROM WORK WHO ARE
PROVIDING. AND SUPPORTING THEIR
FAMILIES. THIS WILL ELIMINATE
THE BETTER OUR- ASK BOTH ON
THIRTEEN FIFTY. THANK YOU
MISTER ST STE IN NORTHERN
SEEKING RECKON. WAS CONSULTING
A CLOSER YOU WISH. SHE WILL
TAKE THAT AS YOUR CLOTHES.
CLARK WELL. OPEN THE ROLE
MEMBERS. IS OUT OF IT ALL
MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE ALL
MEMBERS VOTERS AT ABOUT. THE
CLERK WILL. CLOSE ROLL TIDE
ABOUT I SIX NINE OH ZERO THAT
MEASURE PASSES FILE ITEM FIFTY
THREE. IS IT WOULD BE FOURTEEN
FORTY ONE BY MR LEVINE
CORPORATE. ASSEMBLY BILL
FOURTEEN FORTY ONE BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER LEVINE AND
ACTUALLY THE OIL AND GAS THIS
LIVING THANK YOU VERY MUCH
MISTER SPEAKER AND MEMBERS AB
FOURTEEN FORTY ONE MUCH LIKE
FOURTEEN FORTY BEFORE IT IS
SUPPORTED BY THE DEPARTMENT TO
WORKING. IN AN ARE YOU SEE
UPDATE MODERNIZE THE LANGUAGE
THAT GUIDES THE WAY THAT WE
PLAN FOR EXTRACTING OIL OUT OF
OUT OF CALIFORNIA BY
PRIORITIZING PUBLIC HEALTH AND
THE ENVIRONMENT I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR IN A BOAT. THANK TO ME
SEE NO TO. PAY LOCAL RURAL.
MEMBERS VOTE. ZARA BUT ALL
MEMBERS OF ARE OF A. ALL
MEMBERS VOTE. IT IS OUT OF A.
MR LEVINE MOVES A CALL. MEMBERS
WHERE FILE ITEM FIFTY FOUR A.
B. FOURTEEN FIFTY BY MISTER
LACKEY. CLERK WILL READ
ASSEMBLY BILL FOURTEEN FIFTY BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER LACKEY AND
OTHERS AND ACTUALLY TO CHILD
ABUSE MR LACKEY MAY OPEN THANK
YOU MISTER SPEAKER. THIS IS THE
THIRD YEAR OF DEL DILIGENTLY
WORKED ON THIS PARTICULAR
ISSUE. WHICH ILLUSTRATES HOW
IMPORTANT IT IS TO NOT ONLY ME.
BUT EACH OF OUR COMMUNITIES.
THE INSPIRATION FOR THIS BILL
OKAY FROM. THE DEATH OF GABRIEL
FERNANDEZ WHO WAS AN EIGHT YEAR
OLD CONSTITUENTS. WHO WAS
REPEATEDLY BEATEN. TORTURED AND
EVENTUALLY KILLED BY HIS MOTHER
AND HER BOYFRIEND. HIS BODY WAS
RIDDLED WITH BB GUN PELLETS
CIGARETTE BURNS A FRACTURE IN
THIS GOAL AND THEY FOUND THAT
HE WAS FORCED TO INGEST CAT
FECES. DURING THE LEGISLATIVE
DEVELOPMENT OF THIS BILL.
ANTHONY AVALOS NOR QUATTRO ALSO
SUFFERED SIMILAR ABUSE
RESULTING IN THEIR TRAGIC DEATH.
ALTHOUGH IN EACH OF THESE CASES
THERE ARE MULTIPLE REPORTS OF
CHILD ABUSE. THERE WAS NO
ACTION TAKEN TO PREVENT EITHER
OF THEIR DEATHS. THIS
LEGISLATION RESTORES LAW
ENFORCEMENT'S ABILITY TO ENTER
DATA INTO THE CHILD ABUSE
CENTRAL INDEX OTHERWISE KNOWN
AS KHAKI. FURTHER IT DEVELOPS A
PROCESS FOR AGREED PARTIES THAT
WISH TO BE REMOVED FROM THE
DATABASE OR FEEL THAT THEY
DON'T DESERVE TO BE THERE.
FOLLOWING THE DEATH OF GABRIEL
FERNANDEZ ANTHONY HAVE A LOS
NOR QUATTRO. THE LOS ANGELES
COUNTY BLUE RIBBON COMMISSION
ON CHILD PROTECTIVE. PROTECTION
RECOMMENDED INCREASED
COOPERATION BETWEEN DCFS AND
LAW ENFORCEMENT. THIS
PARTICULAR LEGISLATION WOULD
AFFORD PROFESSIONALS EVALUATING
POTENTIALLY DANGEROUS
SITUATIONS WITH THE WIDEST
PERSPECTIVE POSSIBLE. THIS BILL
IS A STEP FORWARD TO ESTABLISH
A WORKING SYSTEM. THE FORMER
DATABASE PROVED TO HAVE ISSUES
AND PROBLEMS WHICH WE'RE HOPING
TO ADDRESS THROUGH THIS BILL
RATHER THAN RESTRICT THE
CAPABILITIES OF PEACEMAKERS.
ASSEMBLY BILL FOURTEEN FIFTY
WHICH THIS BILL AS A KNOWLEDGE
IS THAT. MAINTAINING THE STATUS
QUO CREATURE CRACK FOR SINCE
THE CASES TO FALL THROUGH.
ALTHOUGH IT'S DIFFICULT TO SAY
THAT THIS LEGISLATION WILL
ELIMINATE ALL CRACKS I DO
BELIEVE THAT A WILL LIMIT THE
LIKELIHOOD OF TRAGEDY SIMILAR
TO GABRIEL ANTHONY AND NOAH.
AND I ASK FOR YOUR SUPPORT ON
THIS MEASURE. THANK YOU MISTER
LACKEY. SEEING NO DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE ON THE ITEM. CLICK CLUB.
IT IS OUT OF OUT ALL MEMBERS
VOTERS OUT OF A- ALL MEMBERS
VOTE. IT IS OUT OF VOTE. WELL.
CLOSE ROLL TIDE ABOUT I SIXTY
FOUR NO ZERO. THAT MEASURE
PASSES. FILE ITEM FIFTY FIVE IS
AB FIFTEEN TWENTY FIVE COVERAGE.
ASSEMBLY BILL FIFTEEN TWENTY
FIVE BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER JONES
SAWYER AND OTHERS AND OAKLAND
CANNABIS MISTER JONES SAWYER.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER AB
FIFTEEN TWENTY FIVE WILL
INCREASE ACCESS TO BANKING
SERVICES FOR CANNABIS
BUSINESSES THIS BILL WILL HELP
BANKS BETTER COMPLY WITH
FEDERAL PORTING REQUIREMENTS IT
ALSO CODIFIES PROTECTION UNDER
STATE LAW. FOR FRIGHT NATURALLY
TO SEE AN ACCOUNT BY SERVICES.
BE IT'S INDEED. AB FIFTEEN
TWENTY FIVE WILL ALLOW THE
STATE CAMPUS LICENSING
AUTHORITY TO SHARE BUSINESS
TRACK AND TRACE DATA AND OTHER
REGULATORY INFORMATION WITH THE
BUSINESS BANK AT THE REQUEST OF
THE BUSINESS. THIS INFORMATION
CAN BE USED BY FINANCIAL
INSTITUTIONS TO VERIFY THAT
EVERY TRANSACTION ASSOCIATED
WITH A BUSINESS PRODUCT IS
LEGAL UNDER STATE LAW
ADDITIONALLY A FIFTEEN TO FIVE
SIMILAR TO LEGISLATION PASSED
IN WATCHING THE STATE WILL
CREATE A HARBOR STATE LAW TO
RETURN. ENTRANCE TO SHOW AN
ACCOUNTANT RIGHTS IS TO THE
STREET THIS BILL C. BI PARTISAN.
CLICK LEVEL THEY'RE ALL.
MEMBERS VOTE. RESERVE ON ALL
MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE. ALL
MEMBERS VOTE. THE DESIRE TO
VOTE. CLICK WELL CLOSE ROLE
CHIDED OUT AYE AYES SIXTY.
KNOWS ONE THAT MEASURE PASSES
FILE ITEM FIFTY SIX AB FIFTEEN
FIFTY ONE CORPORATE ASSEMBLY
BILL FIFTEEN FIFTY ONE BY
FAMILY MEMBER ARAMBULA AND
ACTUALLY THE PROPERTY
ASSESSMENT DOCTOR ARAMBULA.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER AND
MEMBERS TODAY I PRESENT AB
FIFTEEN FIFTY ONE WHICH
PROPOSES MAKING THREE CHANGES
TO THE PROPERTY ASSESSMENT
CLEAN ENERGY PROGRAM ALSO KNOWN
AS PAYS FINANCING. FIRST IT
REQUIRES PACE CONTRACTORS TO
PROVIDE CONSUMERS WITH A HARD
COPY OF A CONTRACT PRIOR. TO
ANY WORK COMMENCING SECOND THIS
BILL PROHIBITS PACE
ADMINISTRATORS FROM CHARGING
CONSUMERS A PENALTY FOR PAYING
OFF THEIR ASSESSMENTS EARLY.
FINALLY THIS BILL WILL PROHIBIT
PACE ADMINISTRATORS FROM CON
CONTRACTING WITH HOME OWNERS
WHO HAVE REVERSE MORTGAGES IT
IS MY HOPE THAT THIS BILL WILL
PROVIDE HOMEOWNERS WHO CHOOSE
TO ENTER INTO A PASTE
ASSESSMENT CONTRACT WITH
ADDITIONAL PROTECTION. AND WITH
A LITTLE MORE INFORMATION ABOUT
THE CONTRACT THEY ARE ABOUT TO
ENTER. MEMBERS I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE. THANK YOU
DOCTOR RAY MILLAND SEEING NO
DISCUSSION. ON THE ITEM. CAR
CLUB IN THE ROLE. OF RESERVE AT
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE.
CLICK WELL THOSE ARE ALL TIED
OWN EYES SIX NINE NO ZERO. THAT
MEASURE PASSES FILE ITEM FIFTY
SEVEN AB FIFTEEN FIFTY TWO. BY
MISS LEMOND CLERK WILL READ AT
SOME LEVEL FIFTEEN FIFTY TWO BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER LIMóN AND
OTHERS AND EXPLAIN TO PEOPLE
INSTRUCTION MAKING CORPORATION
THEREFORE. MS LAMAR YOU MAY
OPEN THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER
IN TWENTY SEVENTEEN THE
LEGISLATURE APPROVED TO AND
GOVERNOR BROWN SIGNED AB SEVEN
THIRTY EIGHT WITH REQUIRED THE
DEVELOPMENT AND ADOPTION OF
NEED AMERICAN STUDIES MODEL
CURRICULUM BY MARCH THIRTY
FIRST OF TWENTY TWENTY THIS
BILL AB FIFTEEN FIFTY TO ENSURE
IS APPROPRIATE FUNDING IS
AVAILABLE TO SUPPORT THE
DEVELOPMENT OF A MODEL
CURRICULUM. ON NATIVE AMERICAN
STUDIES RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN
AYE VOTE. THERE IS A MONTHS NO
DISCUSSION HEY. I'M SORRY.
WOULD YOU LIKE MR ROMMEL'S
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER AND I
TO URGE YOUR SUPPORT ON THIS
BILL IT'S A CHANCE THAT THIS
LEGISLATURE CAN START TO MOVE
FORWARD TO CORRECT THE HISTORY
OF THE PAST OF THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA I URGE A YES VOTE ON
THIS BILL. THANK YOU RAMOS.
SEEING NO OTHER MEMBERS SEEKING
RECOGNITION. THE CAR CLUB THE
ROLE. DESERVE A PERSONAL RESIDE
ABOUT ALL MEMBERS OF. THE
DESIRE TO VOTE CLERK WELL.
CLOSE ROLL TIDE OF THE- I SIXTY
EIGHT NO ZERO THAT MEASURE
PASSES. FILE ITEM FIFTY EIGHT.
A. B. FIFTEEN SIXTY SEVEN
COVERAGE ASSEMBLY BILL FIFTEEN
SIXTY SEVEN BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER
AGUIAR-CURRY AND OTHERS AND
UPLAND PUBLIC RESOURCES MS
AGUIAR-CURRY GOOD AFTERNOON
MISTER SPEAKER AND MEMBERS I
RISE TODAY TO PRESENT AB
FIFTEEN SIXTY FIVE WHICH
REQUIRES STRATEGIC GROWTH
COUNCIL TO RECOMMEND A
COORDINATED STRATEGY FOR
REDUCING EMISSIONS ASSOCIATED
WITH FORESTRY AGRICULTURE AND
URBAN ORGANIC WASTE. REDUCING
WHAT FIRE AND FILLING AND PILE
BURNING OF ORGANIC WASTE ACROSS
THE SECTOR IS CRITICAL TO MEET
OUR EXIST. I'M HERE BECAUSE OF
THE GOALS HOWEVER THIS LACKS A
CALL. STE AND PLAN TO MAXIMIZE
THE BENEFICIAL RE USE OF THESE
ORGANIC MATERIALS. A STRATEGIC
PLAN ON ORGANIC WASTE
MANAGEMENT WILL PROVIDE LONG
TERM TECHNOLOGY NEUTRAL AND
DATAINFORM RECOMMENDATIONS ON
HOW TO SUPPORT THE BENEFICIAL
REUSE OF ORGANIC WASTE AND
BOUNCE IMMEDIATE NEEDS OF LOCAL
COMMUNITIES DISPROPORTIONATE
FORTUNATELY. EXPOSED TO
ENVIRONMENTAL POLLUTION
INCLUDING WILDFIRE SMOKE I
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST YOUR AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU MISS A YEAR
CURRY. SEE NO DISCUSSION DEBATE.
OUR CLUB THEY'RE ALL MEMBERS OF
ARE TO VOTE ALL MEMBERS OF.
DESIRE TO VOTE ALL MEMBERS OF.
THE DESIRE TO VOTE. CLARK WELL
ROLE TIDE ABOUT I SAID THREE NO
ZERO. THAT MEASURE FILE ITEM
FIFTH NINE IS AB FOR NINE NINE
READ AS LEGAL FIFTEEN NINE BY
SO MEMBER CA AND PEACE OFFICERS
MR. THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER.
MEMBERS SOME OF YOU IN THIS
BODY WERE AS FOURTEEN TWENTY
ONE FROM TWO THOUSAND EIGHTEEN.
WHICH CREATED. THE ABILITY
UNDER CERTAIN LIMITED
CIRCUMSTANCES FOR THE PUBLIC TO
GET RECORDS OF INVESTIGATIONS
INTO POLICE ACTIVITY WHEN IT
INVOLVED AMONG OTHER THINGS
SEXUAL ASSAULT PERPETRATED BY
AN OFFICER. WELL UNDER COLOR OF
LAW. AS PROUD TO STAND WITH
THEM IN SUPPORT THAT MEASURE A
FEW YEARS AGO BUT WE'VE SEEN
THAT IT HAS A SIGNIFICANT
LOOPHOLE THAT WE NEED TO
ADDRESS AND THAT IS THIS IF AN
OFFICER IS UNDER ACTIVE
INVESTIGATION WHETHER INTERNAL
AFFAIRS OR CRIMINAL. FOR
SEXUALLY ASSAULTING SOMEONE
WHILE ON THE JOB. THAT OFFICER
UNDER CURRENT LAW CAN RESIGN.
AND IF THEY RESIGN. THE PUBLIC
NEVER HAS THE ABILITY TO GET
THE RECORDS. OF THE
INVESTIGATION INTO THAT SEXUAL
ASSAULT. NOW YOU MAY BE
THINKING THIS IS PROBABLY
FAIRLY RARE AND YOU'RE RIGHT
BUT WE'VE ALREADY SEEN IT
HAPPEN ONCE IN A HAPPENED IN MY
DISTRICT WHERE AN OFFICER WHO
ALLEGEDLY COMMITTED. A RAPE ON
JUST ON THE JOB ON DUTY. A
RESIGNED BEFORE THE
INVESTIGATION INTO THAT WAS
COMPLETED. AND THE RECORDS
NEVER CAME TO LIGHT. THAT'S THE
PROBLEM IT'S HAPPENED BEFORE
AND WILL HAPPEN AGAIN LESS WE
DO SOMETHING AND THE POINT OF
THIS IS NOT TO GO AFTER PEOPLE
THAT WERE FALSELY ACCUSED OF
THINGS. IT'S TO GO AFTER PEOPLE
WHERE THERE'S A SUSTAIN FINDING
THAT THEY COMMITTED SOMETHING
THAT SHOULD DISQUALIFY YOU
PERMANENTLY FROM WEARING A
BATCH. PERIOD AND SEXUAL
ASSAULT ON THE JOB IT'S
CERTAINLY IN THAT CATEGORY AND
WE'VE ALREADY SAID THAT AS A
STATE WHEN WE PASSED SB
FOURTEEN TWENTY ONE. A COUPLE
YEARS AGO. THIS BILL SUPPORTED
BY THE ACLU. SUPPORTED BY THE
NEWSPAPER PUBLISHES PUBLISHERS.
AND WE'RE BUILDING A BROAD
COALITION OF SUPPORT I KNOW
SOME OF YOU HAVE BEEN TALKED TO
BY LAW ENFORCEMENT GROUPS AND I
AM COMMITTING TO YOU I HAVE
BEEN AND WILL CONTINUE TO WORK
WITH THEM TO TRY TO FIND A
COMPROMISE LANDING PLACE IN THE
SENATE WE RAN OUT OF TIME TO DO
AND THEN- I GET ALL. THIS FOR.
BUT I WILL CONTINUE TO WORK.
BECAUSE I BELIEVE LIKE THEY DO
THAT. BEING IN LAW ENFORCEMENT
IS AN HONORABLE PROFESSION AND
MOST PEOPLE THAT ARE IN IT DO
THE JOB WITH INTEGRITY THEY RUN
TOWARDS PROBLEMS THE REST OF US
RUN AWAY FROM. AND THEY DESERVE
OUR SUPPORT I BELIEVE ALL THOSE
THINGS BUT I ALSO BELIEVE THE
TRANSPARENCY IS IMPORTANT THAT
ACCOUNTABILITY IS IMPORTANT AND
THE PEOPLE THAT COMMIT.
POSSIBLY CRIMINAL ACTS AGAINST
BIG GUNS THAT THEY HAVE POWER
OVER. A PROBATION OR PAROLE LEE
THAT SOMEBODY THAT SAYS HEY IF
YOU DON'T DO WHAT I WANT I'M
GONNA BUST YOU AND TAKE YOU IN.
SOME OF THE DAY IS THAT SHOULD
NEVER HAVE A BADGE EVER. AND
THE PUBLIC SHOULD HAVE THE
RIGHT TO KNOW ABOUT THAT
CONDUCT. THAT'S THE LEUPOLD
TRYING TO CLOSE PLEASE HELP ME
DO IT I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN
AYE VOTE. THANK YOU MISS
CUNNINGHAM DR QUIRK WE ARE
RECOGNIZED YES I DON'T THINK
THIS- OFFENSES AS RARE AS
DISTINCT SHOW. BECAUSE BY
DEFINITION WHEN THIS HAPPENS
THERE IS NO RECORD I SAW THIS
HAPPEN IN HAYWARD. WHEN I WAS
ON THE CITY COUNCIL THERE WE
HAVE A ABUSIVE OFFICER WHO
RESIGNED. RATHER THAN FACE.
JUSTICE FROM OUR INTERNAL-
INVESTIGATIONS AND SO I WOULD
JUST VERY MUCH APPRECIATE AN
AYE VOTE ON THIS I AND I KNOW
THE MEMBER FROM SAM THE OBISPO
VERY WELL I TRUST YOU WILL WORK
WITH THE OPPOSITION IN THE-
YEAH RIGHT. WE SEE BILL FOR
TODAY. THANK YOU DOCTOR QUIRK
SEEN NO ADDITIONAL DISCUSSION
ON THE ITEM. CLARK WILL OPEN
THE ROLE MEMBERS OF. WE DESIRE
TO VOTE ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE
TO VOTE. ALL MEMBERS VOTE THE
DESIRE TO VOTE. CLARK WELL THE
CLOSER ROLE CHILD ABOUT EYES
FIFTY SIX KNOWS TO THAT MEASURE
PASSES FILE ITEM SIXTY PASS
RETAIN FILE ITEM SIXTY ONE AB
SIXTEEN TWENTY SIX CARILLO
ASSEMBLY BILL SIXTEEN TWENTY
SIX BY SOMETHING MEMBER ROBERT
RIVAS NECKLACE CIGARETTES
MYSTERY THIS THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER SOME OF THE BILL
SIXTEEN TWENTY SIX THE
CIGARETTE FIRE SAFETY ACT IT
SURE IS THAT THE ALSO GREAT
SOLD IN CALIFORNIA MEET
SPECIFIC SELF EXTINGUISH THE
FIRE SAFETY REQUIREMENTS. AND
IS THAT RESPONSIBLE WITH THE
OFFICE OF THE ATTORNEY GENERAL
ENFORCING THE TOBACCO MASTER
SETTLEMENT AGREEMENT IS
CRITICAL TO CONTINUE TO RECEIVE
A SUCH FUNDS OF WHICH- THEY
PROVIDED A HUNDRED AND NINE MIL.
TO THE STATE. JUST LAST YEAR IN
TWENTY NINETEEN CERTAINLY I AND
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE THANK YOU WAS A BIGGER.
THANK YOU MISS RIVAS. SAYING NO
DISCUSSION DEBATE. CLARK
LIBERAL MEMBERS. IT IS OUR TO
VOTE ALL MEMBERS VOTE DESIRED
ABOUT. ALL MEMBERS VOTE. YEAH
YEAH ALL MEMBERS OTHERS OUT OF
THE CLERK WILL CLOSE ROLE. TELL
YOU VOTE. AS FIFTY THREE NO SIX
THAT MEASURE PASSES. MEMBERS
WITHOUT OBJECTION WE'RE GOING
TO BE MOVING TO TAKE UP. SOME
WORE VITAMINS THE SECOND
READING ITEMS BEGINNING WITH.
AB EIGHT NINETY DOCTOR WOULD
THIS IS WITHOUT REFERENCE TO
FILE. AB.
EIGHT NINETY. THE
CLERK WILL READ. AS I WILL A
NINETY BY SOME REMEMBER WHAT IN
OTHERS AND ACTUALLY THE HEALING
ARTS DOCTOR WOULD YOU MAIL.
THANK YOU MISTER AND MEMBERS.
FROM LATE TWO THOUSAND
SEVENTEEN THROUGH TWO THOUSAND
EIGHTEEN I WAS A MEMBER OF THE
CALIFORNIA HEALTH CARE
FOUNDATIONS FUTURE HEALTH CARE
WORKFORCE COMMISSION. DURING
THAT YEAR I LEARNED A LOT ABOUT
THE CHALLENGES WE FACE WITH OUR
HEALTHCARE WORKFORCE IN
CALIFORNIA. IT CONFIRMED A LOT
OF WHAT I'VE ALREADY KNOW FROM
MY DISTRICT. AND WE HAVE
SIGNIFICANT CHALLENGES IF WE'RE
GOING TO PROVIDE HEALTHCARE FOR
ALL CALIFORNIANS. WE HAVE A
SHORTAGE OF PRIMARY CARE FOR
THE PROVIDERS IN MANY RURAL AND
URBAN AREAS. A TWO THOUSAND
SEVENTEEN UCSF REPORT ESTIMATES
THAT BY TWENTY TWENTY FIVE WE
WILL HAVE A SHORTFALL OF FORTY
SEVEN HUNDRED. PRIMARY CARE
PROVIDERS IN CALIFORNIA AND A
NEED FOR ROUGHLY FORTY ONE
HUNDRED MORE. BY TWENTY THIRTY.
IN IT ALL THIS TO MEET THE
EXPECTED DEMAND BY THE
POPULATION. BETWEEN TWO
THOUSAND EIGHT AND TWO THOUSAND
AND FIFTEEN. THE NUMBER OF
PRIMARY CARE DOCTORS IN
CALIFORNIA DROPPED BY 10% AT A
TIME WHEN THE POPULATION GREW
BY TWO POINT FOUR MILLION
CLEARLY HEADING IN THE WRONG
DIRECTION. LIKE MANY OF YOU OF
I ALWAYS SUPPORTED YOU STILL
FUNDING FOR RESIDENCY PROGRAMS
LOAN FORGIVENESS PROGRAMS WHICH
ARE GREAT TOOLS ARE COSTING
TENS OF MILLIONS OF DOLLARS OF
EVERY EVERY YEAR AND WE WILL
NOT WILL NOT GET US TO THE
POINT OF MEETING OUR WORKFORCE
NEEDS. WE SIMPLY CANNOT BUY OUR
WAY OUT OF THE SHORTAGE OF
PRIMARY CARE PROVIDERS. THERE
IS A TOOL THAT I HAVE COME TO
BELIEVE IS NEEDED IN CALIFORNIA
AND THAT'S REFLECTED IN A
NINETY WHICH WILL A NATIONALLY
ACCREDITED NURSE PRACTITIONERS
WITH A MINIMUM THREE YEARS
ADDITIONAL REAL LIFE CLINICAL
EXPERIENCE. AND PRACTICE
PROVIDE SERVICES WITHOUT THE
NEED FOR STANDARDIZED SPUR OF
PROTOCOLS BY PHYSICIANS. ISN'T
WOULD BE REQUIRED PASS A
NATIONAL A LICENSURE EXAM THAT
ASSURES COMPETENCY. EXAM WOULD
NEED TO BE VALIDATED BY AN
ENTITY WITHIN DEPARTMENT
CONSUMER AFFAIRS AND IF NOT
TEAM SUFFICIENT SUPPLEMENTAL
COMPONENTS FOR A CALIFORNIA
SPECIFIC EXAM. WOULD BE
DEVELOPED THE REQUIRED. A
MEMBERS FROM APPROACH ASSEMBLY
APPROPRIATIONS STRENGTH IN THE
CLINICAL TIME BEFORE IN PEACE
COULD PRACTICE WITHOUT
PROTOCOLS. WHAT CALIFORNIA BE
BREAKING NEW. GROUND THIS BILL.
ACTUAL NOT. IN TWENTY TWO OTHER
STATES. THEY DO THIS ALREADY.
AT THE VETERANS ADMINISTRATION
THEY DO THIS ALREADY AND IN
THAT NOT SO RURAL AREA OF THE
DISTRICT OF COLUMBIA THEY DO
THIS ALREADY- AS CURRENTLY
WRITTEN. THE BILL WOULD BE
DISTRICT. IN THESE. THE SCOPE
OF PRACTICE FOR RESPECT TO.
THERE ARE COUNTLESS DAY THAT
SHOW AND PRAC SAFELY AND
BECAUSE- WITH OUT THE OVERSIGHT
OF POSITION. BUT NONE THE LESS
INCLUDED TO DO A TIMER IN THE
BILL TO SHOW THAT ALL THE MOST
AND PEACE WILL BE ABLE TO PRAY
WAY. NO NO NURSE PRACTITIONER
RIGHT I OF SCHOOL QUALIFY UNDER
THIS BILL. AND I AGREE WITH
THAT APPROACH I BELIEVE THE
BILL STRIKES A REASONABLE
BALANCE BETWEEN THE NEED TO
PROVIDE MORE ACCESS CARE AND
THE NEED TO MAINTAIN QUALITY
HEALTHCARE SERVICES. I BELIEVE
THIS BILL WILL HELP LARGE URBAN
AS WELL AS RURAL AREAS. THE 59%
OF NURSE PRACTITIONERS ARE
PROVIDING PRIMARY CARE ALREADY.
WHILE ONLY 17% OF PHYSICIANS DO
SO. NURSE PRACTITIONERS ARE
MORE LIKELY TO ACCEPT MEDICARE
OUR AND MEDICARE AND THEN THEIR
PHYSICIAN COUNTERPARTS 90% OF
NURSE PRACTITIONERS WILL LIKELY
SEE MEDI CAL MEDICARE PATIENTS
COMPARED TO THEIRS TO ABOUT 64%
FOR THEIR POSITION
COUNTERPARTS. THESE NUMBERS AND
COUNTLESS OTHERS FROM STUDIES
I'VE READ SHOWN TO ME THAT
ACCESS IS INCREASED WHEN
SUPERVISION REQUIREMENTS ARE
REMOVED. ANALYSIS A PEER
REVIEWED RESEARCH AND THERE IS
A LOT OF IT HAVE CONCLUDED THAT
IN PEACE PROVIDE CARE OF
COMPARABLE QUALITY AS
PHYSICIANS EVEN WITH AN PIECE
PRACTICING WITH OUT POSITION-
SERVICE OVERSIGHT. ASIAN SAYS
IS HIGH WITH THERE'S PRACTICE.
PRIOR THE OF PART PART
INTRODUCED THE BILL AND THAT
WITH OPPONENTS. I ASKED HIM FOR
EVIDENCE TO THE CONTRARY. AND
I'VE RECEIVED NINE. WHAT I HAVE
HEARD IS ANECDOTAL STORIES
ABOUT THE PROBLEMS BUT THIS IS
NOT. YOU'D STUDIES I WOULD
EXPECT FROM THE MEDICAL
COMMUNITY. THE BILL SUPPORTED
BY A BROAD COALITION IS
INCLUDING CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF HEALTH
FACILITIES CALIFORNIA SCHOOL
BASED HEALTH ALLIANCE ESSENTIAL
ACCESS HEALTH THE STEINBERG
INSTITUTE S. CI YOU A. R. P. R.
C. R. C. AT LEAST FIFTY OTHER
ORGANIZATIONS I RESPECTFULLY
ASK YOUR EYE BELOW. THEY GET
BACK TO WHAT DOCTOR ARAMBULA
YOUR RECOGNIZED. THANK YOU
MISTER SPEAKER. YOU KNOW I WANT
TO START IF I CAN- BY
RESPECTING OUR COLLEAGUE AND
CHAIR OF HEALTH WHO HAS WORKED
ON THIS ISSUE AND CONTINUES TO
CHAMPION THIS ISSUE. I MUST
RESPECTFULLY DISAGREE WITH THE
CURRENT BILL THAT IS BEFORE US
AND WOULD ASK THIS BODY TO
SPEND A LITTLE MORE TIME BEING
DELIVERED. NOW I WOULD HAVE
PERSONALLY APPRECIATED AN
OPPORTUNITY TO HAVE SEEN THIS
IN COMMITTEE UNFORTUNATELY I
WAS NOT HERE LAST YEAR WHEN
THIS BILL WAS HEARD. IN
COMMITTEE. AND BELIEVE THAT IN
THE SECOND YEAR WE SHOULD HAVE
AN OPPORTUNITY TO CONTINUE TO
WORK ON THIS BILL IF IT DOES
NOT GET OFF THIS FLOOR TODAY.
NOW I WANT TO RECOGNIZE MANY OF
THE NURSE PRACTITIONERS WHO I
WORKED WITH FROM CHRISTY PALETA
CHEN TEARS ON TO DENNIS LEVINE
TO SANDY. BRITNEY AND CHRIS
TOLD PEOPLE WHO HELPS TO EXPAND
OUR PRACTICE AND WERE WONDERFUL
TO WORK WITH THIS IS NOT AN
ISSUE FOR ME OF QUALITY AND
TRAINING THIS IS AN ISSUE OF
GETTING IT RIGHT. AND THIS
VERSION TO ME STILL HAS ISSUES
IN ITS CURRENT FORM WHETHER IT
BE WITH THE LACK OF A CORPORATE
BAR OR ABILITY TO HIRE
PHYSICIANS AT HOSPITALS WHICH
IS NOT PRESENT IN THIS BILL.
AND I JUST ASK US TO DO WHAT WE
SAY WE DO IN MEDICINE WHICH IS
TO MEASURE TWICE AND CUT ONCE.
THIS BILL IS NOT QUITE READY IN
pTHIS BODY ALLOW US MORE TIME SO
THAT WE CAN GET IT RIGHT IN
THIS UPCOMING YEAR. THANK YOU
MISTER SPEAKER. THEY GET A
CURRICULA MR LOW YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
MISTER SPEAKER MEMBERS I A RISE
TO URGENT AYE VOTE I A RISE TO
ALSO THANK THE MEMBER FROM
HILLS BURKE OUR HEALTH ASSEMBLY
HEALTH CHAIR OF THE BUSINESS
PROFESSIONS COMMITTEE STAFF
MYSELF OF THE AUTHOR AND
STAKEHOLDERS HAVE HAD A NUMBER
OF CONVERSATION OUR OF
CONVERSATION SINCE INCEPTION.
AND IN FACT I RECALL- BEING IN
MY DISTRICT- DURING THE BREAK A
LAST YEAR TO WHICH- DOCTOR
WOULD ASKED ABOUT MY OPINION ON
THIS AREA OF TOPIC TO WHICH THE
FALL UP THE FOLLOWING MONTH AND
THEN THE FOLLOWING EACH AND THE
FOLLOWING. I SO WE HAVE BEEN IN
DEEP CUTS. WITH THIS IS. SINCE
INCEPTION AS AS STAKEHOLDERS
ALIKE AND OPPOSITION SO I JUST
WANTED TO. CLARIFY THAT FOR
MEMBERS A SHOULD THERE BE ANY
ADDITIONAL CLARIFICATION
REQUIRED ON SAYING IF THERE'S
BEEN AN EXHAUSTIVE
CONVERSATIONS ON THESE ISSUES I
CERTAINLY AS THIS BILL
HOPEFULLY MOVES FORWARD OTHER
THE OTHER OPPORTUNITIES ON
CONCURRENT AND OTHERWISE FOR.
THE FREE POLICY COMMITTEE IN
THE ASSEMBLY TO HEAR THIS AGAIN
TO WHICH I KNOW THAT WILL ALSO
HAVE FEEDBACK BUT AS WE SIT
HERE TODAY JUST GIVE LET'S
THEY'VE I'M LIVE I REGION I
BUILT. THANK YOU LOWE. THIS OF
US HERE RIGHT. THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER YOU KNOW AN IRA A WELL
IN SOME OF THIS BILL YEAH I
LIKE TO THINK OUR COLLEAGUE
FROM SANTA ROSA HILLS BIRD
WHATEVER IT MAY BE. FOR HIS
LEADERSHIP ON THIS ISSUE AND
FOR OFFERING THIS BILL YOU KNOW
I WANT TO THANK HIS STAFF WAS
WORKED FOR THE BETTER PART OF A
YEAR. I WITH ALL STAKEHOLDERS
ON IN AN EFFORT TO CRAFT THE
BEST POSSIBLE LEGISLATION THAT
WE HAVE HERE THIS AFTERNOON.
YOU KNOW I AM A PROUD SUPPORTER
OF THIS BILL BECAUSE IT WILL
DIRECTLY IMPACT IN A VERY
POSITIVE AND PRONOUNCED WAY.
THOUSANDS OF PEOPLE IN THE
DISTRICT THAT I REPRESENT AND
AS I MENTIONED IN THE PAST ON
THIS ASSEMBLY FLOOR AND
PERSONAL CONVERSATIONS WITH
MANY OF YOU. I REPRESENT ABOUT.
A RELATIVELY LARGE DISTRICT.
PART OF FOR COUNTIES AND
INCLUDES PARTS OF THE CENTRAL
COAST OF CALIFORNIA CONSIDERED
SUBURBAN RURAL. AND I REPRESENT
TENS OF THOUSANDS OF
FARMWORKERS. FARMWORKERS LIVING
IN A RURAL PARTS OF CALIFORNIA
WHO STRUGGLE TO FIND ACCESS TO
QUALITY AFFORDABLE HEALTH CARE.
NOW THIS BILL WILL ALLOW NURSE
PRACTITIONERS TO PRACTICE TO
THE FULL EXTENT OF THEIR
TRAINING AND ABILITIES. NOW
LOOK I SERVED AS A COUNTY
SUPERVISOR FOR EIGHT YEARS
PRIOR TO MY TIME HERE THE STATE
ASSEMBLY. ON THE LOCAL LEVEL
THE BEST POLICY IDEAS THAT I
SUPPORTED. WITH THOSE THAT WE
NEGOTIATED. THAT WE NEGOTIATED
AND REFINED OVER SEVERAL MONTHS.
AND IN MOST CASES IT TOOK
SEVERAL YEARS. NOW MY LOCAL
GOVERNMENT EXPERIENCE TAUGHT ME
THAT POLICY IDEAS REFINED OVER
TIME WITH THE INVOLVEMENT OF
ALL STAKEHOLDERS LEAD TO THE
BEST POSSIBLE OUTCOMES AND
THAT'S THE BEST POSSIBLE
OUTCOMES FOR PEOPLE. NOW THE
POLICY IDEAS FORWARDED BY THIS
BILL ASSEMBLY BILL EIGHT NINETY
ARE NOT NEW IDEAS. THE FAT IN
FACT OVER TWENTY FIVE STATES
ALREADY HAVE DONE THIS EXACT
SAME THING. THE POLICY PROPOSAL
BEFORE US TODAY HAS BEEN TRIED
IT HAS BEEN TESTED. AND IT HAS
BEEN PROVEN TO WORK. THIS
POLICY IDEA HAS BEEN DISCUSSED
IT HAS BEEN DELIBERATED THE
RESEARCH IS COMPLETE WE HAVE
THE DATA OUT BEFORE US.
CALIFORNIANS NEEDS TO STAND UP
AND DELIVER ON THE PROMISE TO
EXPAND ACCESS TO CARE. THIS
POLICY WILL DO JUST THAT. AND
IT'LL DIRECTLY IMPACT THE
FARMWORKERS IN THOSE LIVING IN
UNDERSERVED AREAS OF THE
DISTRICT I REPRESENT. AND IN
SIMILAR REGIONS ACROSS OUR
STATE ASSEMBLY BILL EIGHT
NINETY IS GOOD PULIC POLICY.
AND IT IS THE RIGHT THING FOR
US TO DO SO I ORIGIN AYE VOTE
ON THIS BILL THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER. THERE WAS RIVAS DOCTOR
EGGMAN. YOU'RE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER
MEMBERS I ALSO RISE. IN SUPPORT
OF THIS BILL- IN I APPRECIATE
THE CONVERSATION MORE SAYING
THIS IS GOING TO FAST TOO FAST
I CAN MEMBERS OF MY VERY FIRST
YEAR. IN OFFICE TWENTY THIRTEEN
AS I WAS CARING FOR MY SISTER
IN LAW SHE WAS DYING HE
SHOULDN'T HAVE HEALTHCARE
INSURANCE WHICH IS THE REASON
THAT HER CANCER WENT
UNDIAGNOSED. UNTIL THE LAST TWO
MONTHS OF HER LIFE WHEN WE
FINALLY WERE ABLE TO HAVE IT
DIAGNOSED. AND I REMEMBER THE-
THE CONVERSATION GOING ON THE
COMMITTEE SAYING THAT THAT KERR
WASN'T GOOD ENOUGH. AND I
REMARK AT THE TIME WELL IT
CERTAINLY WOULD HELP SOMETHING
WOULD HAVE HELPED. IN THE
AFFORDABLE CARE ACT WENT INTO
SHE DIED IN. AUGUST OF TWENTY
THIRTEEN IN THE AFFORDABLE CARE
ACT WENT INTO EFFECT IN JANUARY
OF TWENTY FOURTEEN. HER LIFE
WOULD HAVE BEEN DIFFERENT.
COULD HAVE BEEN POTENTIALLY
SAVE. ISSUE THAT ACCESS TO
HEALTH CARE WE KNOW WE'VE
EXPANDED HEALTH CARE TO A LOT
MORE PEOPLE NOW. THIS YEAR UP
TO TWENTY SIX FOR THOSE
UNDOCUMENTED. NOW WE WANT TO GO
EVEN FURTHER FOR THOSE SENIORS.
BUT WE NEED CARE PROVIDERS OF
WE DON'T HAVE CARE PROVIDERS.
THEN EXPANDING ACCESS DOESN'T
REALLY MEAN NYTHING THEY'RE
JUST WORDS. TWENTY TWO OTHER
STATES ALREADY DO THIS. AND
BEFORE MANY OF YOU ARE ALIVE
NINETEEN SIXTY FIVE IS WHEN THE
NURSE PRACTITIONER OF
PROFESSION WENT INTO AFFECT
TIME IMPROVED AS A COMBAT ARMY
MEDIC I WORK WITH PLENTY OF
THEM IN THE MILITARY SERVING IN
THE VA SYSTEM IN THE MILITARY
SYSTEM. AS WELL AS WITH
OPPOSITION TO SYSTEM WE NEED
EVERY WE'RE NOT SAYING THAT
NURSE PRACTITIONERS WILL TAKE
THE PLACE OF POSITIONS WE WOULD
NEVER SAY THAT BUT IT'S ANOTHER
OPTION FOR PRIMARY CARE. IS IN
RURAL AREAS WHERE I ALSO
REPRESENT BUT I ALSO. STOCKTON
CALIFORNIA WHICH IS A- URBAN
COMMUNITY. WITH A HIGH NEED OF
CARE. VERY HIGH WRITTEN A
LETTER TO THE PROPERTY AND VERY
LOW NUMBERS OF PROVIDERS.
THAT'S A SYSTEM A RECIPE FOR
DISASTER AS WE SEE HIV
TUBERCULOSIS THINGS LIKE THAT
GOING UP SOME PRIMARY CARE. LET
ME HAVING MORE PROVIDERS THEIR
TO SEE FOLKS AT THE FRONT END
WILL REALLY HELP US IMPROVE OUR
HEALTH CARE OUTCOMES. SO YEAH
WE'VE BEEN TALKING ABOUT THIS
FOR YEARS I THINK TO SAY IT'S
GOING TO FAST IS A LITTLE
DISINGENUOUS AND THIS IS JUST
THE FIRST HOUSE. SO THEY'RE
STILL A LITTLE BIT MORE TIME TO
MAKE SURE EVERYBODY GETS TO THE
TABLE AS WE CONTINUE THIS
CONVERSATION. PROVIDING QUALITY
CARE AND ACCESS TO CALIFORNIANS.
THANK YOU DOCTOR EGGMAN MISTER
VOEPEL. YOUR RECOGNIZE. MISTER
SPEAKER MEMBERS SO I CAUTION ON
THIS BILL I DO NOT SUPPORT IT
RIGHT NOW IT NEEDS MORE WORK.
IT NEEDS TO COME BACK TO US
NEXT SESSION HERE'S WHY. I
SPENT THIRTY NINE YEARS. AS AN
INSURANCE EXPERT AT LEAST I
THOUGHT I WAS AN EXPERT FROM
THE. DESIGNING HEALTH PLANS FOR
LARGE CORPORATIONS. AND HERE'S
THE DEAL ON THIS ONE. NURSE
PRACTITIONERS. OUR NOBLE IN
GREAT BUT THERE ARE ALSO A WAY
OF SAVING MONEY FOR LARGE
CORPORATIONS AND OTHER HEALTH
PLANS IF YOU FINAL PEOPLE OFF
TO NURSE PRACTITIONERS AND
AVOID. PHYSICIANS WHO ARE IN
CHARGE THEN THAT IS A COST
SAVER IT IS ALSO PROVIDING
INADEQUATE SERVICE IN SOME
CASES SO I CAUTION THIS BODY IN
VOTING FOR THIS BILL RIGHT NOW
I MAY SUPPORT IN THE FUTURE BUT
IT NEEDS WORK. BECAUSE THIS BY
AN OUTLET. FOR LOWERING QUALITY
OF CARE IN SAVING MONEY FOR
VARIOUS ENTITIES THAT WE MAY
NOT EVEN KNOW. THANK YOU SIR.
THANK YOU MISS VOEPEL MINS
PETRIE-NORRIS HEARING. THANK
YOU MISTER SPEAKER I RISE TODAY
IN SUPPORT AS AB EIGHT NINETY I
THINK THAT THE ARGUMENTS IN
SUPPORT OF THIS POLICY ARE
REALLY QUITE COMPELLING I'M AS
I'VE SHARED WITH THE AUTHOR I
DO HAVE SOME CONCERNS ABOUT AS
THE CREATION OF THE NEW BOARD
IN THE STRUCTURE AND MANAGEMENT
AS SPECIFIED IN THE BALLOT. AND
HER SHE FRIENDS AS THEY OPENED
TO WORK WITH THAT TO REFINE NOT
AS SAD AS THIS BILL MOVES
TOWARD BUT TODAY I WILL BE
SUPPORTING THE BILL AND WERE TO
WORKING WITH AN ATTITUDE. IT TO
HELP. MR JOHNSON YOU'RE
RECOGNIZE THANK YOU SPEAKER I
RISE TO SPEAK ON A EIGHT NINETY
I WILL BE SUPPORT THIS BILL
TODAY TO HELP THIS BILL MOVE
FOR I DO HAVE CONCERN THAT I
WILL TO SEE ADDRESSED AT THE
BILL MOVES FOR TO PROCESS MY
COMMUNITY IS CURRENTLY IN UNDER
OF COMMUNITY MEDICALLY AND I
BELIEVE THAT THIS BILL WILL
GIVE IT A CHANCE. TO HAVE SOME
HEALTH CARE PROFESSIONALS. THIS
BILL DOES NOT GUARANTEE THAT
NURSE PRACTITIONERS WILL BE
SERVING MY DISTRICT OR EVEN
ROLE DISTRICT BECAUSE IT LACKS
A REQUIREMENT THAT THEY DO A
MINIMUM TIME OF SERVICE AND
UNDERSERVED COMMUNITIES. I AM
ALSO CONCERNED AT THIS MAY LEAD
TO A DIVIDED HEALTHCARE SYSTEM
WHERE THOSE THAT CAN AFFORD IT.
GO TO THE DOCTOR BY THOSE THAT
CANNOT AFFORD IT GO TO NURSE
PRACTITIONERS THE PEOPLE OF MY
DISTRICT UTILIZED MEDI CAL. AT
A HIGH RATE ESPECIALLY
UNDOCUMENTED YOUTH A SYSTEM
THAT IS CURRENTLY UNDER SERVED
BY PHYSICIANS. AND I DO WANT TO
MAKE SURE THAT IF THAT NOT IF
THAT WHEN THIS BILL MOVES
FORWARD. WE DON'T FORGET TO
KEEP WORKING ON WAYS TO GET.
MORE PHYSICIANS AND DISTRICTS
THAT LOOK LIKE MINE WE NEED
MORE HEALTH CARE PROFESSIONALS
PERIOD. I BELIEVE THAT THIS
BILL PROVIDES A BETTER
OPPORTUNITY FOR MY CONSTITUENTS
IN THE STATUS QUO. THIS BILL
DOES. NOT SOLVE ALL OF THE
HEALTH CARE ACCESS PROBLEMS
STILL NEEDS TO CONTINUE TO BE
FLESHED OUT. I WILL BE VOTING
FOR THIS BILL TODAY BUT IS A
RESERVE MY RIGHT TO CHANGE MY
VOTE WHEN HIS BILL RETURNS TO
THE FLOOR. MEMBERS ARE
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR IBM.
THEY WERE CHAU SORRY DOCTOR
QUIRK YES I RISE IN SUPPORT OF
AB EIGHT NINETY I WOULD LIKE TO
SAY THAT. PHYSICIANS OFTEN RUN
INTO SITUATIONS THAT THEY CAN-
SERVICE AND THEY SEND THEM ON
TO SPECIALISTS I HAVE FULL
FAITH THAT AN EXPERIENCED NURSE
PROFESSIONAL WHO RUNS INTO A
SITUATION THAT SHE DOESN'T FEEL
COMPETENT TO SERVE CAN ASK FOR
HELP THEN I THINK THAT'S QUITE
ADEQUATE. AGAIN THIS IS A VERY
TOUGH BUILT TOUGHER THAN OTHER
STATES OTHER STATES HAVE NOT
HAD A PROBLEM WITH THIS I URGE
I STRONGLY URGE AND I'VE OUT.
THANK YOU DA QUIRK. SEE NO
OTHER MEMBERS RECKONED ON THE I.
DOCTOR WOULD YOU MAY CLOSE
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER IN
THANK YOU MEMBERS FOR YOUR
COMMENTS AND- I APPRECIATE THEM
VERY MUCH UNITING COME TO THIS
EASILY AND TWENTY FIFTEEN AS A
FRESHMAN LEGISLATOR THIS BILL
CAME TO US RIGHT BILL SIMILAR
TO CAME WHEN I SAT ON BE IN P.
AND IT INVOLVES FOR- FOR IT
BECAUSE I WASN'T CONVINCED. AND
I MY DAD. THEN I WENT TO THE
WORKFORCE COMMISSION I SPENT
MORE TIME IN MY DISTRICT I
BECAME ABSOLUTE CONVINCED THAT
THIS TOOL WILL HELP US- BY.
OKAY IN. UNITY CAN ALSO
COMMUNITY. LIKE. S. ENOUGH I
DON'T BELIEVE IT POTENTIALLY
FINAL OF PEOPLE OFF ANYWAY I
I'D GO BACK TO THE FACT THAT
THE IS THIS BILL AS IS A
STRICTER THAN IT IS IN TWENTY
TWO OTHER STATES. I'M NOT SURE
THAT THAT MEANS YEAH I THINK
IT'S READY MOVE ON. IF TWENTY
TWO OTHER STATES CAN DO THIS
SAFE. PROVIDE HIGH QUALITY CARE
FOR PATIENTS. WITH A LESSER
RESTRICTIVE BILL I'M NOT SURE
WHY THIS MENTION PROCESS. THE
I. BUT WE MIGHT WE MIGHT WHEN
ASKED PRACTITIONERS TO GARY
THEY WOULD SERVE AN UNDERSERVED
AREA- OFFERS. AS A PERIOD TIME
I WOULD SAY THEN IF WE'RE GOING
TO DO THAT WE'RE GOING TO FORCE
PEOPLE TO GUARANTEE THEM TO
BEGIN THAT WERE ALL HEALTHCARE
PROVIDERS AND NOT JUST THERE'S
PRACTITIONERS. AND THAT MIGHT
NOT TASTE SO GOOD. PEOPLE BUT
THE REALITY IS WE NEED TO GET
CARE TO PEOPLE WHO NEED IT THE
MOST. SOME OF SAID THIS WILL
PROVIDE TWO TIERS OF CARE. I
SAY IT IT IT ALREADY WE ALREADY
HAVE TWO TIERS OF CARE. PEOPLE
GET CARE. IF PEOPLE DON'T CARE
MY GOAL IS. TO GET MORE CARE TO
MORE PEOPLE WHO NEED IT SO THAT
THEY DON'T HAVE TO GO TO A
EMERGENCY ROOM. SO THEY DON'T
HAVE TO STRESS OUT OUR SYSTEM
DON'T HAVE THE COSTA SIS MORE.
WE KNOW THAT WE PEOPLE DON'T
HAVE A MAY. HOME THEY WAIT
UNTIL LONGER- AND THEY DID
THEIR THEIR- FRIENDS GET MUCH
WORSE. AND WHAT DID THEY DO
THEY ARE UP IN A MURDER ROOM.
DESPERATE ONE TO CHANGE THAT I
BELIEVE THIS IS NOT. THE TOTAL
SOLUTION IS IT STILL A TOOL. I
HOPE WE BEFORE. I TO WORK.
MISSION WITH AN LOOK FORWARD TO
YOUR AYE VOTE THANK YOU FOR
MUCH. TO THANK YOU DOCTOR WITH
CLERK WILL OF THE ROLE. ON OF.
THE. ALL MEMBERS VOTERS TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE.
CLICK WELL. CLOSE TIED ABOUT
AYE AYES FIFTY SO KNOWS WHY DAY
PASSES. MEMBERS WE ARE GOING TO
MOVE BACK UP TO THE TOP FILE
ITEM ONE. AND THIS IS AB THIRTY
ONE. COVERAGE A SOME BILL
THIRTY ONE BY SO THE NUMBER IT
AND AN ACT TAXI TAKE A
IMMEDIATELY TO LEVY THIS GARCIA
THANK YOU I'M ASSIST MEMBERS AB
THIRTY ONE SIMPLY. THE. TWO
TWENTY TWENTY SEVEN ON AND SO
HEALTH IS GET CLOSER TO A
GENDER NEUTRAL TAX CODE I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE. FAMOUS GARCIA SENIOR
DISCUSSION A CLERK WILL OVER
THE ROLE. OF DESIRE TO VOTE ON
MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE. ALL
OF. IT IS OUR TO VOTE. THE
CLERK WILL CLOSER ALL TIED UP I
SIXTY SO KNOWS. THAT MEASURE
PASSES. PASS RETAIN OF VIOLENCE
TWO AND THREE THIS IS FILE ITEM
FOR. AB FOR EIGHT. CAREER
ASSEMBLY BILL FOR OH EIGHT BY
SOMETHING FRAZIER AND OTHERS
AND EXPLAIN TO VEHICLES MR
FRAZIER YOU MAY OPEN THANK YOU
MISTER SPEAKER MEMBERS AB FOR
IT IS SIMPLE BILL THAT WAS
REMINDED PROCESS THAT A
DISABLED VET LET'S GO THROUGH
TO OBTAIN A SPECIAL LICENSE
PLATE SPECIFICALLY THE BILL
ENABLE CALVET AND CUT AND THE
COUNTY VETERANS SERVICE
OFFICERS CONFIRM. THAT THIS. IS
TO CAN. TO FOR OUR TO OUR FORTY
VETERAN. MEMBERS ARE
RESPECTFULLY I YOUR I'VE- THANK
FRAZIER'S NOTICE KASHER TO BE
ON THE ON A- CAR CLUB IN THE
WRONG. MEMBERS IS OUT OF A ON
MEMBERS VOTER ARE TO VOTE. ON
THEM VOTE. THE DESIRE TO VOTE.
CLICK WELL CLOSER ALL TELL VOTE
ICE KNOWS YOUR- THAT MAY PASSES.
PAST RETAIN A FILE ITEM FOR
FIVE ITEM SIX. IS A- SIX FORTY
EIGHT BY MR NESS. CLICK WAIT
ASSEMBLY BILL SIX FORTY EIGHT
BY SOMEONE AS THEIR AND I TO ON
THE PROGRAM THIS. THANK YOU
MISTER. SB SIX FORTY EIGHT WITH
A CONSUMER PRIVACY PROTECTIONS
AROUND WELLNESS PROGRAMS BY
DOING THE FOLLOWING ONE
ESTABLISHING CLEAR REQUIREMENTS
ON FARE COLLECTION AND USE OF
PERSONAL INFORMATION TO
PROHIBITING INTENTIONAL
DISCRIMINATION AND WELLNESS
PROGRAMS THREE. REQUIRING
TRANSPARENCY AND WELLNESS
PROGRAMS INCLUDING DATA USAGE
AND ROLY RIGHTS STATE AND
FEDERAL LAW AND FOR GRANTING
WELLNESS PROGRAM ENROLLEES THE
RIGHT TO VIEW IT. COME PROMOTED
AS A WAY TO SUPPORT HEALTHY
BEHAVIORS AND IMPROVE HEALTH
OUTCOMES FOR PARTICIPANTS
HOWEVER MANY COME WITH UNSPOKEN
TRADEOFFS THEY REQUIRE
PARTICIPANTS TO GIVE UP THEIR
PERSONAL DATA INCLUDING
SENSITIVE PERSONAL HEALTH
INFORMATION AND EXT INCH FOR
UNSUPPORTED PROMISES OF AND IN
SOME. TO WIN RE BIRDS THIS
SINCE TRADE OFF CAN THREATEN A-
PRIVACY AND CAN TO PUT. FOR
DISCO. A. B. C. FORTY EIGHT
DOES NOT BAN WELLNESS. BUT BILL
UPON COMMITMENT TO EXISTING
CONSUMER AND WORKER PRIVACY
PROTECTIONS WITH THAT I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE THANK YOU. THE REST IS
AREA SAYING NO TO DEBATE ON THE
I CLERK LOW. WELL IS THERE
ABOUT ALL MEMBERS OTHERS ARE
ABOUT.
ALL MEMBERS OTHERS OUT
OF A.
MISTER NAZARIAN MOVES A
CALL. FILE ITEM SEVEN. AB SEVEN
THIRTY TWO COVERAGE ASSEMBLY
BILL SEVEN THIRTY TWO BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER BONTA AND OTHERS
AND ACTUALLY TO INCARCERATED
PERSONS WHICH ONE THANK YOU
MISTER SPEAKER AND COLLEAGUES
AB SEVEN THIRTY TWO WOULD
IMPROVE THE QUALITY OF
REPRODUCTIVE HEALTH CARE FOR
INCORPORATED AND CAL IN COUNTY
JAIL. IN STATE PRISONS POINTS
THERE CARE TO HAVE A HEALTHY
PREGNANCY CALIFORNIA LAW HAS
SOME IMPORTANT REQUIREMENTS IN
THIS REGARD BUT THERE'S STILL
MUCH MORE TO DO AB SEVEN THIRTY
TWO WOULD CODIFY INTO LAW.
REGULATIONS FOR STATE PRISONS
AND EXTEND EXISTING PROTECTIONS
THAT APPLY IN CALIFORNIA STATE
SINCE TWO COUNTY JAILS ON THE
SEVEN THIRTY TO. COUNTY JAIL TO
BE REQUIRE TO SCHEDULE IN MAY.
TRICKS EXAM PRENATAL CARE IS. A
AIDES TO LOWER BANKS AND LOWER
HOUSE ALLOW IN TO HAVE A SO
PERSON. DURING CHILDBIRTH TO
GIVE PREGNANT INMATES ACCESS TO
COMMUNITY PRO AND PROVIDE
INMATES WITH POST PARTUM
EXAMINATIONS THESE ARE ALL
CURRENTLY REQUIRED IN STATE
PRISON A. B. C. TO FOR THE
BUYERS JAY AND PRISON IS TO
PROVIDE. MEANT PIES A COST.
PROHIBIT THE SHOCK OF ALL
PREGNANT INMATES TRANSFER TO
HOSPITALS IT WOULD ALSO
PROHIBIT TAY'S RING OF AND
SOLITARY CONFINEMENT OF
PREGNANT INMATES CALIFORNIA
SHOULD PROVIDE DIGNIFIED HUMANE
AND COMPASSIONATE CARE SERVICE
DOZENS OF TO INCARCERATED
PREGNANT CALIFORNIANS WHETHER%
IN STATE PRISON OR JAIL AB
SEVEN THIRTY TWO SURE THIS
HAPPENS IF YOU MEMBERS I
RESPECTFULLY. FRONT I BOUGHT.
THE BOND WAS KILLED. MR
REMEMBER I TALKED THE AUTHOR
ABOUT JUST LISTED THE BITS
THESE GRAY TO WORK ON IT BUT
THE ONLY CONCERN IS WITH SOME
OF MAY MISS SOMEONE HAS LIKE
ISSUE I CAN BE AROUND YOUR
POPULOUS INMATES SOME OF THE
SALT OF IN MAY SO WE WANT TO
MAKE SURE THOSE OR SAY. AND
SOMETIMES OR SEGREGATE DO PATH
THAT THE. OTHERS ARE SAID SIGN
ARE YOU AGREED TO LOOK INTO
THAT ALEX. TO WORK WITH YOU A
ADDRESS THOSE. THANK YOU.
RESPONDING DRESS THAT IN YOU
CLOTHES SEEING NO. ADDITIONAL
THIS ON THE ADAM. SPONTE MAY
NOT. I JUST WANNA APPRECIATE MY
COLLEAGUES MILAGRO FOR TOUCHING
BASE IN PROVIDING INPUT BASED
ON HIS OWN EXPERIENCES ABOUT A
WAY TO IMPROVE THE BILL I THINK
THAT IS A LOT OF SENSE OF WHAT
YOU'RE SAYING THE IDEA THE BILL
IS TO ASSUME THAT THE HEALTH
AND WELFARE. THE CARD WERE
TAKEN CALIFORNIANS EN THE COULD
BE SOME CIRCUMSTANCES. ARE
WHERE WE HAVE AN ANTENNA
CONSEQUENCES AND CURRENT
FRAMING OF THE BILL SO I DO
APPRECIATE UP. TO HEAR FROM YOU
AND TO CONTINUE TO WORK WITH
YOU. GOING FORWARD WITHOUT I
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE VOTE.
THE RESPOND TIME WITH THE CLERK
WILL OPEN THE ROLE. IT IS OUT
OF THAT ALL MEMBERS OF OUR
DESIRE TO VOTE. ALL MEMBERS
VOTE. IT IS OUT OF OUT. CLARK
WELL CLOSER ALL TIES BUT I
FIFTY FIVE NO ZERO. THAT
MEASURE PASSES FILE ITEM EIGHT
IS AB SEVEN NINETY KERKORIAN
ASSEMBLY BILL SEVEN NINETY BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER LEVINE AND
ACTUALLY DEPRIVE THE EMPLOYER.
MR LEVINE. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
MISTER SPEAKER IN MEMBERS AB
SEVEN NINETY WOULD REQUIRE
CONTRACTORS ENTRY INTO PERSONAL
SERVICE CONTRACTS WITH
COMPANIES OPERATING IN THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA THAT HAVE
THE MARKET VALUATION OVER ONE
BILLION DOLLARS TO PER
EMPLOYEES WILL PERFORM THE
SERVICES IN THAT CONTRACT A
NOTICE THAT THEY HAVE THE RIGHT
TO FORM JOIN OR ASSIST LABOR
ORGANIZATIONS AS STIPULATED IN
SECTION SEVEN OF THE NATIONAL
LABOR RELATIONS ACT. SPREAD OF
COURSE BARGAINING THAT FOLLOWED
PATH. HOW ARE A IN NINETEEN
THIRTY FIVE LED TO DECADES OF
FASTER AND FAIR ECONOMIC GROWTH
THAT PERSISTED INTO THE LATE
NINETEEN SEVENTIES. SINCE THE
NINETEEN SEVENTIES DECLINING
UNIONIZATION HAS FUEL TO RISING
INEQUALITY AND STALLED ECONOMIC
PROGRESS FOR THE BROAD AMERICAN
MIDDLE CLASS THE DRINKING
AMERICAN MIDDLE CLASS. ECONOMIC
DATA MAKE CLEAR. THAT INCOME
INEQUALITY HAS HIT CALIFORNIA
PARTICULARLY HARD. UNION IS A
WOULD HELP MANY THIS ANY. AS
RESEARCH BY THE ECONOMIC POLICY
INSTITUTE HAS SHOWN UNIONS MAKE
WAGES AMONG OCCUPATIONS MORE
EQUAL BECAUSE THEY GIVE A LARGE
WAGE BOOST TO LOW AND MIDDLE
AGE OCCUPATIONS VENTA HIGHWAY
TALK TO PATIENTS EIGHTY SEVEN
NINETY WOULD HELP ENSURE THAT
THE PERSONAL SERVICE CONTRACT
WORKERS COVERED BY THIS BILL.
ARE AWARE OF THEIR RIGHT TO
UNIONIZE. CANCER POINT POSITION
AND IF IT'S AND THE OVERALL
QUALITY OF LIFE FOR ALL IN
CALIFORNIA THANK YOU ASKED FOR
AYE VOTE ON EIGHTY SEVEN NINETY.
FAMOUS LIVING. SENIOR
DISCLOSURE BAIT. OUR CLUB RURAL
MEMBERS ABOUT DESIRE TO VOTE ON
MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO
VOTE.
ALL MR LEVINE MOVES CALL.
FILE ITEM NINE IS AB EIGHT
THIRTY EIGHT CORPORATION
ASSEMBLY BILL EIGHT THIRTY
EIGHT BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER A
MINUTE OTHERS ACTUALLY TO
AGRICULTURE DOCTOR EGGMAN.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH IS BIGGER
MEMBERS TODAY ARE RIGHT TO
PRESENT AB EIGHT THIRTY EIGHT
WHICH CREATES THE FORMER EQUITY
INNOVATION CENTER. THE CENTER
WILL PROVIDE SOCIALLY
DISADVANTAGED FARMERS WITH
ACCESS TO NEW AND EXISTING
SERVICES AND TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE THIS BILL HAS
RECEIVED BIPARTISAN SUPPORT I
RESPECTFULLY ASK PRIVATE. THANK
YOU DOCTOR AYMAN SEEING NO
DISCUSSION DEBATE CLERK WILL
OPEN THE ROLE. OF HIS ART OF A.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE ABOUT.
ALL MEMBERS OTHERS OUT OF THE
CLERK WILL. CLOSER ROLE. TELL
YOU VOTE. I FIFTY SEVEN NO ZERO.
THAT MEASURE PASSES. WE
DISPENSED WITH FILE ITEM TEN
FILE ITEM ELEVEN IS AB EIGHT
NINETY SEVEN BY MISTER MEDINA
CORKERY ASSEMBLY BILL EIGHT
NINETY SEVEN BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
MEDINA AND ACTUALLY COMMUNITY
COLLEGES MR MEDINA. THANK YOU
MISTER SPEAKER AND MEMBERS AB
EIGHT NINETY SEVEN WOULD CHANGE
THE PERCENTAGE OF HOURS THAT A
PART TIME TEMPORARY. EMPLOYEE
MAY TEACH TO UP 285% OF THE
HOURS PER WEEK THAT A FULL TIME
EMPLOYEE- CAN TEACH. UNDER THE
67% THRESHOLD MANY FACULTY
MEMBERS TEACH IN MULTIPLE
CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY COLLEGE
DISTRICTS AT THE SAME SAME TIME
PIECE TOGETHER OF FULL TIME
SCHEDULE. THESE INSTRUCTORS ARE
TIMES REFERRED TO AS FREEWAY
FLYERS. LIMITS THEIR ABILITY TO
DISSIPATE IN THE CAMPUS
COMMUNITY AND TO BE A RESOURCE
TO STUDENTS. AB EIGHT EIGHTY
SEVEN WILL HELP IMPROVE STUDENT
SUCCESS AT THE COMMUNITY
COLLEGE LEVEL WHILE ALSO
IMPRESSED. THE HARD. FACED BY
THE TIME FACULTY. THIS BILL AS
RECEIVED BY PARTISAN SUPPORT
AND NO VOTES. AT YOUR BOAT. HE
MISSED SEEING PRESSURE CLERK
WILL OPEN THE. WHAT ABOUT ALL
MEMBERS THERE ABOUT. ALL
MEMBERS VOTE DESIRE TO VOTE.
KIRK WELL CLOSE ROLL TIDE BUT I
SIXTY ONE NO ZERO THAT MEASURE
PASSES FILE ITEM TWELVE IS AB
ELEVEN FORTY. OPERATE ASSEMBLY
BILL ELEVEN FORTY BY FAMILY
MEMBER MARK STONE AND ACTUALLY
BUSINESS. MR STONE EMAIL BEEN
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER
MEMBERS IS HOW SHOULD TAKE
GREAT PRIDE IN HAVING PROVIDE
THE LEADERSHIP TO PASS THE
EARNED INCOME TAX CREDIT A
NUMBER OF YEARS AGO. WELL RIGHT
NOW THE DATA SHOWS THAT UPWARDS
OF TWENTY FIVE CENTS OF THAT
CREDIT GO TO TAX PREPARATION
SERVICES SO ALL THIS BILL DOES
IS IT ASKS TAX PREPARERS TO LET
PEOPLE KNOW UP FRONT WHAT THEIR
STATE OR COSTS ARE SO THAT
THAT. TAXPAYER HAS A BETTER
UNDERSTANDING OF WHAT IT COULD
BE IN IN FOR WITH HIRING A TAX
PREPARER. IT ALSO PROVIDES
ADDITIONAL AVENUES TO THAT
THOSE TAXPAYERS. CAN STAND WILL
RETAIN PREP SIR ARE I
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE VOTES.
THERE WAS DOWN SENIOR KASHER
BAY. CLUB LONGER. FIRST OF IS
OUT OF THE ALL MEMBERS VOTER
DESIRE TO THE- ALL MEMBERS VOTE
THIS TO THE. CLARK WELL THOSE
ARE ALL TIED ABOUT EYES FORTY
THREE KNOWS FOURTEEN THAT
MEASURE PASSES MEMBERS WITHOUT
OBJECTION WE'RE GOING TO MOVE
NEXT TO TAKE UP FILE ITEM.
EIGHTEEN AB THREE FORTY FIVE BY
MR MURATSUCHI. CLOCK RATE
ASSEMBLY BILL THREE FORTY FIVE
ASSEMBLY MEMBER MURATSUCHI AND
ACTUALLY THE NATURAL RESOURCES
MURATSUCHI. MUCH MEMBERS AB
THREE FOUR FIVE IS ABOUT
ENVIRONMENTAL JUSTICE THIS IS A
TOP PRIORITY BILL FOR THE
ENVIRONMENT JUSTICE COMMUNITY.
THIS BILL WILL PRINT ACT OUR
CHILDREN AND FAMILIES
ESPECIALLY THOSE LIVING IN LOW
INCOME COMMUNITIES OF COLOR
FROM THE HARMFUL HEALTH X. OF
OIL DRILLING IN THE BACKYARDS
WERE CHILDREN LIVE AND PLAY AND
GO TO SCHOOL. AND WE'RE THE
SICK AND ELDERLY RECEIVE
MEDICAL CARE. THIS BILL WILL
REQUIRE THE SECRETARY OF
NATURAL RESOURCES TO CREATE AN
ENVIRONMENT JUSTICE PROGRAM AND
TO ADOPT REGULATIONS TO PROTECT
PUBLIC HEALTH AND SAFETY NEAR
OIL AND GAS EXTRACTION
ACTIVITIES INCLUDING A MINIMUM
SETBACK DISTANCE. A PUBLIC
HEALTH AND SAFETY BUFFER ZONE
BETWEEN OIL EXTRACTION
ACTIVITIES AND SCHOOLS
PLAYGROUNDS HOMES AND
HEALTHCARE FACILITIES. STUDY
STUDY LINK A PROXIMITY TO OIL
AND GAS WELLS TO INCREASED RISK
OF ASTHMA AND OTHER RESPIRATORY
ILLNESSES PRETERM BIRTHS HIGH
RISK PREGNANCIES AND CANCER.
DESPITE THE OVERWHELMING
EVIDENCE OF THE NEGATIVE PUBLIC
HEALTH IMPACTS OF OIL DRILLING
NEAR VULNERABLE COMMUNITIES
CALIFORNIA LAW CURRENTLY DOES
NOT PROHIBIT OIL AND GAS
OPERATORS FROM DEALING FROM
DRILLING NEAR A SENSITIVE AREAS
SUCH AS SCHOOL PLAYGROUNDS AND
HEALTHCARE FACILITIES. ATTACK
TO PROTECT OUR CHILDREN AND
FAMILIES HEALTH AND SAFETY
BUFFER ZONES ARE WIDELY ADOPTED
IN OTHER STATES COUNTIES AND
CITIES. THE STATE OF MARYLAND
HAS ADOPTED A ONE THOUSAND FOOT
MINIMUM SAFETY BUFFER ZONE. THE
STATE OF COLORADO HAS A FOR A
FIVE HUNDRED FOOT MINIMUM
SAFETY ZONE HERE IN CALIFORNIA.
THE CITY OF CARSON ADOPTED A
SEVEN HUNDRED FOOT SEVEN
HUNDRED FIFTY FOOT A SAFETY
ZONE AND EVEN. THIS OF DALLAS
TEXAS ADOPTED A FIFTEEN HUNDRED
FOOT MINIMUM SAFETY ZONE. SHE
ON US. WE SHOULD BE ABLE TO DO
BETTER THAN DALLAS TEXAS AND
STANDING UP FOR ENVIRONMENTAL
JUSTICE. LAST NOVEMBER THE
GOVERNOR'S OFFICE ANNOUNCES
PLAN TO CONSIDER BUFFER ZONES
AROUND OIL WELLS IN OR NEAR
RESIDENTIAL NEIGHBORHOODS
SCHOOLS AND HOSPITALS TO
PROTECT ALL CALIFORNIANS AB
BEFORE FIVE WILL GUIDE THE
GOVERNOR'S RULE MAKING PROCESS
BY REQUIRING AN UNSPECIFIED
MINIMUM HELP THE SAFETY BUFFER
ZONE. OF AN UNSPECIFIED SINCE
THIS WILL ALLOW THE NATURAL
RESOURCES AGENCY THE
FLEXIBILITY NEEDED TO USE
SAFETY SETBACKS WITH OTHER
MITIGATION MEASURES WHILE
ADDRESSING CONCERNS ABOUT JOBS
NOW LET ME ADDRESS. THE
QUESTION OF JOBS THIS BILLS
POTENTIAL IMPACT ON JOBS IN THE
FALL SO FEEL INDUSTRY. LET ME
MAKE IT CLEAR THAT THIS BILL IS
NOT TRYING TO SHUT DOWN
EXISTING OIL WELLS AND IT'S NOT
TRYING TO SHUT DOWN FUTURE OIL
DRILLING WE JUST WANT TO MAKE
SURE THAT OIL WE WANT TO MAKE
OIL DRILLING SAFER BY REQUIRING
SOME COMMON SENSE SET BACKS TO
PROTECT CHILDREN AND FAMILIES.
NOW I'M A BIG SURPRISE GOOD
UNION JOBS IN CASE ANYONE IS
EVER WONDER I HAVEN'T THE 7% ON
THE LABOR FRONT SCORECARD AND
I'M VERY PROUD OF THAT. WE ALL
WANT GOOD UNION JOBS BUT NOT AT
THE EXPENSE OF THE HEALTH AND
SAFETY OF CHOI FAMILY LIVING
NEAR THE OIL DRILLING SITES.
THE PREVIOUS VERSION THIS BILL
RECALL A TWENTY FIVE HUNDRED
FOOT SETBACK FOR ALL NEW OIL
DRILLING THE CURRENT BILL. FOR
HIT TO HAS. SAN BUT PER I'D
**** RESORT IS A- WITH
FLEXIBILITY AND ESTABLISHING A
MAY SAFETY. I READ I AM CAN. I
AM COMMITTED TO CAN. TO WORK
WITH THE OP. TO THEIR- AND WITH
THAT A RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YA
VOTE. MS REYES. YOUR RECORD AS-
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER
MEMBERS. WE ALL KNOW OIL WELLS
CAN EMIT TOXIC AIR CONTAMINANTS
AS WELL AS PARTICULAR MATTER
THAT IS DAMAGING TO PUBLIC
HEALTH ESPECIALLY FOR THOSE
LIVING IN CLOSE PROXIMITY TO
THE WELLS. YET THERE ARE NO
STATEWIDE STANDARDS FOR
SETBACKS. THE ADMINISTRATION
HAS EXPRESSED ITS INTENT TO
ESTABLISH RULES DESIGNED TO
PROTECT RESIDENTS AND
COMMUNITIES NEAR OIL AND GAS
EXTRACTION SITES. THIS BILL
WILL SIMPLY MAKE SURE THAT THE
ADMINISTRATION WILL FOLLOW UP
ON THIS INTENT AND CONSIDER
MEANING FULL SET BACKS. THE
BILL ALLOWS YOU TO MINISTRATION
FLEXIBILITY SO THAT THEY WOULD
FULLY BE ABLE TO CONSIDER
DIFFERENT DISTANCES DISTANT
SETBACKS FOR DIFFERENT
CONDITIONS. FOR EXAMPLE THEY
CAN CREATE SMALLER SET BACKS.
WHERE ARE. ACTION OR- MEASURES.
THIS BILL ISN'T ABOUT CUTTING
OIL PRODUCTION IT'S ABOUT
PROTECTING THE COMMUNITIES THAT
SURROUND PRODUCTION
INFRASTRUCTURE. CLEARLY GOOD
JOBS THAT MUST BE PROTECTED AND
I HAVE SPOKEN WITH THE AUTHOR
ON THIS PARTICULAR ISSUE IN THE
AUTHOR ASSURES ME THAT THAT IS
ONE AREA THAT HE WILL CONTINUE
TO WORK WITH THE OPPOSITION TO
MAKE SURE THAT THOSE GOOD JOBS.
ARE PROTECTED. I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR YOUR AYE VOTE. MS RIVAS
YOUR RECOGNIZED THANK YOU
MISTER SPEAKER AS A MEMBER FROM
LOS ANGELES I EPRESENT AND
HAVE GROWN UP IN COMMUNITIES OF
THAT ARE DISPROPORTIONATELY
AFFECTED BY POOR AIR QUALITY
AND CONTAMINATED SOILS THAT'S
WHY I RISE IN SUPPORT OF AB
THREE FORTY FIVE WHICH PROVIDE
STATE REGULAR. IS NOT TO
EXPLORE NOT ADDITIONAL
REGULATIONS ARE NECESSARY TO
PROTECT OUR MOST VULNERABLE
COMMUNITIES ESPECIALLY CHILDREN
AND FAMILIES THANK YOU. I THINK
IT WAS RIVAS. SEE NO ADDITIONAL
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON THE
ITEM. MISTER MURSHID SHE MAKE
CLOTHES IF YOU WISH THANK YOU
VERY MUCH HI AGAIN I AM
COMMITTED TO WORKING WITH THE
OPPOSITION TO ADDRESS THE
CONCERNS THE LESS PROTECT OUR
CHILDREN AND FAMILIES FROM THE
MOST HARMFUL PUBLIC HEALTH
IMPACT OF OIL DRILLING IN THE
BACK BIRDS RESPECTFULLY FOR A
AYE VOTE. THE CLERK WILL. THE
SAN ALMA VOTERS AND OF A. ALL
MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MISTER MURATSUCHI MOVES A
CALL. MEMBERS BACK CAN FILE
ORDER FILE ITEM THIRTEEN. AB.
FOURTEEN TWENTY SIX. GREGORY
ASSEMBLY BILL FOURTEEN TWENTY
SIX BY SOME REMEMBER
BOERNER HORVATH AND OTHERS AND
ACTUALLY THE PUBLIC RESOURCES.
THIS BOERNER HORVATH YES THANK
YOU MISTER SPEAKER MEMBERS AB
FOURTEEN TWENTY SIX PROJECTS
SENATE NO FREE STATE BEACH FROM
ANY TRANSPORTATION
INFRASTRUCTURE THAT WOULD
ENCROACH ON THE STATE PARK. THE
BILL CODIFIES THE SUBSTANCE OF
TWO AGREEMENTS THAT WERE SIGNED
BY CONSERVATION ORGANIZATIONS
THE ATTORNEY GENERAL THE
FOOTHILL EASTERN TRANSPORTATION
CORRIDOR AGENCY CALTRANS THE
NATURAL RESOURCE AGENCY THE
NATIVE AMERICAN HERITAGE
COMMISSION AND THE STATE PARK
AND RECREATION COMMISSION
SETTLING MULTIPLE LAWSUITS.
THAT SPANNED NEARLY A DECADE
THEY AGREEMENT ALMOST AN BUT IN
THE STATE PARK AND WILL SHOULD
LET THAT ARE PROTECTED FROM
STRUCK. AB FOR TWENTY SIX BUT
PROTECTION OF THE STATE BEACH
IMPROPER. BY CODIFY THE INTENT
I AGREEMENT SIGNED BY STATE
AGENCIES ENVIRONMENTAL
CONSERVATION. LOW EDITION IS. I
RISK FOR YOUR VOTE. SEEN
NOTICED OR DEBATE ON THE BILL.
CAR CLUB ROLE. OUT OF IT ON
VOTERS TO VOTE. ALL MEMBERS
VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE. THE.
CLICK WELL. CLOSE ROLL TIDE BUT
ICE FORTY NINE KNOWS FOURTEEN
THAT MEASURE PASSES. FILE ITEM
FOURTEEN IS AB FOURTEEN FIFTY
EIGHT BY DR QUIRK CLERK WILL
READ ASSEMBLY BILL FOURTEEN
FIFTY EIGHT BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
QUIRK AND ACTUALLY THE CANNABIS
DOCTOR QUIRK. THANK YOU SPEAKER
IN MEMBERS AB FOURTEEN FIFTY
EIGHT ADDRESS IS A KEY ISSUE IN
THE MANUFACTURING PROCESS FOR
CANNABIS. FOR EDIBLES THIS
BILL. UP WILL. ALLOW THAT THE
CERTIFICATE OF ANALYSIS REPORT
A VARIANCE OF 12% RATHER THAN
10% FOR THE NEXT ARE FOR THE
YEAR OF TWENTY TWENTY ONE. ARE
CURRENTLY TECHNOLOGY IS NOT
ROBUST ENOUGH TO TESTED THE
EXISTING REQUIREMENT OF TEN
PERCENT. UP THERE IS NO
OPPOSITION I ASK YOUR AYE VOTE.
THEY GET A QUIRK SENIORS KASHER.
CLARK WELL OPEN THE ROLE. OF
SORRY ABOUT ALL MY VOTERS ARE
OF A- ALL MEMBERS VOTE. THE
DESIRE TO VOTE. HI. CLICK WELL.
CLOSER ALL TITLEIST NO SEVEN.
THAT MEASURE PASSES ASCERTAIN
ON FILE ITEMS FIFTEEN. SIXTEEN
AND SEVENTEEN. MEMBERS ARE
GOING TO MOVE DO CONSENT
CALENDAR. AS A MEMBER WE SURE
MOVE ADAM FROM THE CONSENT
CALENDAR SEEING AND HEARING
NONE THE CLERK WILL READ THE
SECOND DAY CONSENT CALENDAR
ASSEMBLY BILL THREE TWENTY FIVE
BUY SOMETHING NEVER PROMISE AND
ACTUALLY THE SELF SERVICE
STORAGE FACILITIES. HER WILL
OPEN THE ROLE ALL MEMBERS
VOTERS ARE TO VOTE THIS IS THE
CONSENT. CALENDAR. ALL MEMBERS
VOTERS ARE ABOUT. ALL MEMBERS
VOTERS ARE TO VOTE. CLARK WELL
CLOSER ROLL TIDE UP I SEVENTY
NO ZERO THE CONSENT CALENDAR IS
ADOPTED.
MEMBERS WE HAVE A
NUMBER OF BILLS ON CALL BUT WE
ARE GOING TO MOVE TO THE
ORIGINAL- ASSEMBLY THIRD
READING FILE AND PICK UP WHERE
WE LEFT OFF THAT'S FILE ITEM
SIXTY TWO. ASSEMBLY READING A.
B. SIXTEEN TWENTY SEVEN. BY
MISTER RIVAS CORKERY ASSEMBLY
BILL SIXTEEN TWENTY SEVEN BY
SOMETHING MEMBER ROBERT RIVAS
AND I CLING TO CIGARETTES
MAKING PREPARATION THERE FOR
MYSTERY THAT MISTER SPEAKER
COLLEGES IN THE BILL SIXTEEN
TWENTY SEVEN IS RELATED TO
ENHANCEMENTS TO CALIFORNIA'S
TOBACCO STATUTE OVER MAINTAIN
OUR STATE TOBACCO DIRECTORY AS
PREVIOUSLY MENTIONED CALIFORNIA
RECEIVES ALMOST A HUNDRED AND
FIFTY MILLION PER YEAR IN
TOBACCO MASTER- THE SETTLEMENT
FUNDS THE ANNUAL PAYMENTS ARE
CONDITION ON CALIFORNIA'S
ENACTMENT AND ENFORCEMENT OF AN
ESCROW STATUTE. A STATUE WHICH
POSES FINANCIAL OBLIGATION ON
TOBACCO COMPANIES ARE NOT PARTY
TO THE MASTER SETTLEMENT
AGREEMENT OTHERWISE CALLED NON
PARTICIPATING MANUFACTURERS
THIS BILL WOULD CLARIFY THIS
THE LAW TO EIGHTY ATTORNEY
GENERAL'S ENFORCEMENT OF OUR
MASTER SETTLEMENT AGREEMENTS
ALL PATIENTS BY TARGETING NON
COMPLIANT BACK ACTORS ACTING
AGAINST ELEVATED RISK. FACTORS
EVERY DAY WITH AGENCIES FORSMAN.
RISK ASK FOR VOTE THANK YOU
MISTER. THANK YOU MAY RIVAS.
SEE NO DISCUSSION DEBATE ON THE
ITEM. CLICK LIBERAL ALL MEMBERS.
IT IS OUT ABOUT ALL MEMBERS ARE
OF A- ALL MEMBERS OTHERS TO
VOTE. CLICK WELL. CLOSE ROLL
TIDE BUT I FIFTY ONE KNOWS NINE
THAT MEASURE PASSES FILE ITEM
SIXTY THREE. IS AB SEVENTEEN
SEVENTY FIVE BY MS RAMOS. THE
CLERK READ ASSEMBLY BILL
SEVENTEEN SEVENTY FIVE BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER REYES AND I
PLAN TO LAND USE MS RACE THANK
YOU MISTER SPEAKER AND MEMBERS.
A TODAY I PRESENT TO YOU AB
SEVENTEEN SEVENTY FIVE WHICH
REQUIRES THAT THE DEPARTMENT OF
JUSTICE BE NOTIFIED WHEN A
CHANGE IS MADE TO A LOCAL LAND
USE PLAN. AB SEVENTEEN SEVENTY
FIVE WILL PROMOTE GREATER
TRANSPARENCY AND ACCOUNTABILITY
IN ENVIRONMENTAL JUSTICE
INTEGRATION INTO LINE LAND USE
PLANNING. THE CHANGES TO THIS
BILL ARM MINOR AND TECHNICAL IN
NATURE I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR AYE VOTE. THANK YOU
ADDRESS SIGNAL DISCLOSURE
DEBATE. CLARK WELL OF THE WRONG.
IT IS OUT OF OUT ALL MEMBERS
VOTERS ARE TO VOTE. ALL MEMBERS
OF OUR DESIRE TO VOTE.PARK
WELL ALL TIED UP EYES FORTY
EIGHT. NO SEVENTY. THAT MEASURE
PASSES FILE ITEM SIXTY FOUR. AB
SEVENTY NINETY SIX BY MR LEVINE
CORKERY ASSEMBLY BILL SEVENTY
NINETY SIX BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER
LEVINE AND EXPLAIN TO COMMUNITY
CARE FACILITIES MR BEAN THANK
YOU VERY MUCH MISTER SPEAKER
AND MEMBERS AB SEVENTEEN NINETY
SIX WILL PROHIBIT THE
DEPARTMENT OF SOCIAL SERVICES
FROM GRANTING A CRIMINAL RECORD
CLEARANCE OR EXEMPTION UNTIL IT
RECEIVES AN INDIVIDUAL STATE
AND FEDERAL CRIMINAL RECORD
BEFORE ALLOWING THEM TO WORK IN
A COMMUNITY. CARE FACILITY ARE
BASS FOR ABOUT. THEY YOU MISS
LIVING SENIOR DISCUSS OF EIGHT
LOCAL OF THE ROLE. ON VOTE IS
OUT OF OUT ALL MEMBERS OUT OF A.
ALL MEMBERS OF DESIRED VOTE.
CLARK WELL CLOSE THE ROLE
TELLING THE VOTE I THREE KNOWS
THAT MEASURE PASS. MEMBERS I
WOULD LIKE TO MENTION THAT.
REMIND YOU RATHER THAT ASSEMBLY
MEMBER RAY S. IS CELEBRATING A
BIRTHDAY TODAY HAPPY BIRTHDAY.
MEMBERS WE HAVE FIVE ITEMS ON
CALL. THE SESSION SCHEDULE IS
AS FOLLOWS TUESDAY JANUARY
TWENTY EIGHTH CHECK IN SESSION
WEDNESDAY JANUARY TWENTY NINTH
CHECK IN SESSION AND THURSDAY
JANUARY THIRTIETH A FOUR
SESSION IS AT NINE AM.
MEMBERS
WE ARE GOING TO LIVE THE CALL.
MEMBERS ARE GOING TO LIVE THE
CALL IN AB THREE FORTY FIVE BY
MISTER MURATSUCHI THE CLERK
WILL POST MEMBERS MOTIVATIONAL.
ALL MEMBERS ON WHICH TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTER WISHED ABOUT.
CLARK WELL. CLOSE A ROLL CALL
VOTE EYES FORTY ONE. YES TWENTY
EIGHT THAT MEASURE PASSES.
MEMBERS I AM COMPARED TO LIVE
THE CALL ON MR NECESSARY ENDS
A. B. SIX FORTY EIGHT THE CARD
PROPOSED. ALL MEMBERS WHICH TO
VOTE ON MEMBERS ON WHICH TO
VOTE. CLARK WELL. CLOSE ALL
TIED ABOUT ICE ONE. KNOWS
TWENTY. THAT MEASURE PASSES.
MEMBERS I AM PREPARED TO LIFT
THE CALL ON MR KILEY S. A. B.
ONE SIX TWO CORPS COMPOSED OF
MEMBERS VOTER WHICH TO VOTE.
THE THIRTY IS NOT THE. MAGIC
NUMBER MR CAN.
MR KILEY I THINK
I WILL CLOSE THE ROLE. IN TALLY
THE VOTE AYE AYES THIRTY ONE.
KNOWS ELEVEN. THAT MEASURE
FAILS. MR LEVINE HAS TWO
REMAINING ITEMS ON CALL.
MEMBERS APRIL AT THE CALL ON AB
FOURTEEN FORTY ONE BY MR LEVINE
CARGO POSTS. ALL MEMBERS VOTERS
TO VOTE. ALL MEMBERS VOTE. WHO
DESIRE TO VOTE CLERK WILL.
CULTURAL THAILAND EYES FORTY
ONE NO SEVENTY. THAT MEASURE
PASSES.
A WHEN. MEMBERS I AM
PREPARED TO LIFT THE CALL ON
FILE ITEM THIRTY FOUR A. B.
SEVEN NINETY BY MR LEVINE THE
CLERK WILL POST. ALL MEMBERS
VOTE. DESIRE TO VOTE. ALL
MEMBERS VOTERS ADDED THOUGH.
ALL MEMBERS OTHERS AT A VOTE.
CLOSER ALL TODD ABOUT AYE AYES
THIRTY SEVEN KNOWS TWENTY FOUR
THAT MEASURE FAILS AND MISTER
LEVY NOTICES RECONSIDERATION.
IN THE ABSENCE OF OBJECTION THE
QUORUM CALL IS LIFTED. I'M
SORRY MEMBERS THE QUORUM CALL
IS NOT LIFTED. QUORUM CALLS NOT
LIFTED.
MISTER CALDERON FOR
YOUR MOTION THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER I AT THE REQUEST OF THE
AUTHOR I AM GIVING A ONE DAY
NOTICE TO REMOVE ITEM A FOR A.
B. TWO TWENTY ONE CRISTINA
GARCIA FROM THE INACTIVE FILE.
THE CLERK WILL NOTE. NOW
MEMBERS QUORUM CALL LIFTED
WE'RE MOVING TO A GERMAN IN
MEMORY. MAN PLEASE TAKE YOUR
CONVERSE OFF OF THE FLOOR.
MEMBERS PLEASE TAKE YOUR SEATS.
WHERE THE GERMANS TO MEMORY.
PLEASE GIVE YOUR RESPECTFUL
IT'S HERE COLLEAGUE OR TAKE
YOUR CONVERSATIONS OFF OF THE
GREEN CARPET.
MEMBERS PLEASE
TAKE YOUR CONVERSATIONS OFF OF
THE FLOOR IT'S CLEAR THE AISLES.
OR TAKE YOUR SEATS SO YOU MAY
GIVE YOUR ATTENTION DEAR
COLLEAGUES. RETURNING THE
MEMORY. THANK YOU MEMBERS THE
FOLLOWING MEMBERS ARE GRANTED
PRAYER FOR ME PERMISSION TO
SPEAK ON A GERMAN IN MEMORY. MR
BONTA YOU ARE RECOGNIZED. THANK
YOU MISTER SPEAKER AND-
COLLEAGUES TODAY I RISE TO
GERMAN IN MEMORY OF ARTHUR OR
ART SHANKS THE SECOND. WHO
PASSED AWAY IN DECEMBER TWENTY
NINTH TWENTY NINETEEN AT THE
AGE OF SIXTY FOUR. ART WAS A
REVERED COMMUNITY PARTNER AND
LEADER WHO DEDICATED HIS LIFE
TO CREATING HOPE AND
OPPORTUNITY. FOR MANY IN
OAKLAND AND THE GREATER EAST
BAY. ART GROUP OAKLAND AND TOOK
AN EARLY INTEREST IN
CONSTRUCTION AND THE TRADE.
UNDER THE GUIDANCE OF HIS LATE
FATHER ARTHUR SHANKS THE FIRST.
HIS EXTENSIVE EDUCATION
TRAINING AND EXPERIENCE A
POWERED HIM TO ACT WITH THE
NINETEEN EIGHTY NINE LOMA
PRIETA EARTHQUAKE TOOK OUT PART
OF THE CYPRESS FREEWAY. IN WEST
OAKLAND ART NEW THAT SKILLED
LABOR WAS NEEDED TO REBUILD THE
FREEWAY AND OTHER IMPACTED
AREAS THIS INSPIRED HIM TO HELP
ESTABLISH THE CYPRESS MANDELA
PROJECT. IT CONSTRUCTION PRE
APPRENTICESHIP PROGRAM THAT
FOCUSED ON TRAINING. AND
EMPOWERING PEOPLE OF COLOR LOW
INCOME INDIVIDUALS AND OTHER
GROUPS TRADITIONALLY UNDER
REPRESENTED IN THIS FIELD.
UNDER THE YOUR SHIP OF OUR THE
CYPRESS MANDELA TRAIN CENTER
HAS. THE LOOK IS A THOUSANDS OF
INTO. WHO HAVE PART. IN THE
CENTER FREE. INTENSIVE TRAINING
PROGRAM. BEYOND THE PACKED
SKILLS THE CENTER HAS HELPED
SOME. ASPECTS YOUNG PEOPLE AND
FORMALLY INCARCERATED
INDIVIDUALS LEARN NECESSARY
LIFE SKILLS THAT HAVE TURNED
THEIR LIVES AROUND. ART WAS
DEDICATED TO CREATING
MEANINGFUL CHANGE IN THIS
COMMUNITY AND FOR MORE THAN
THREE DECADES HE DID JUST THAT
AND MORE HE FIERCELY BELIEVED
THAT ALL PEOPLE REALLY NEED IS
A CHANCE TO PROVE THEMSELVES A
CHANCE TO RISE ABOVE THEIR
CIRCUMSTANCES. AND CONTRIBUTE
TO THE BETTERMENT OF THEIR
COMMUNITIES ARTS DEVOTED
SERVICE HAS LEFT A LASTING
IMPACT AS COMMITTEE AND HIS
LEGACY WILL CONTINUE TO LIVE ON
THROUGH THE LIVES. OF THE MANY
HE TOUCHED. THE SPEAKER AND
COLLEAGUES I RESPECTFULLY ASK
THAT WE INJURED IN MEMORY OF
ART SHANKS. THANK YOU MISTER
BONTA. MR GRAY YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED FOR GERMAN MEMORY.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER
MEMBERS I RISE TODAY ON BEHALF
OF THE TWENTY FIRST ASSEMBLY
DISTRICT TO ADJOURN THE MEMORY.
OF A LONG TIME CAPITOL STAFFER
A MEMBER OF THE ASSEMBLY FAMILY
A GOOD FRIEND BOB SANDERS WHO
PASSED AWAY ON DECEMBER
SEVENTEENTH. BOB WAS BORN
OCTOBER TWENTY NINTH NINETEEN
FORTY ONE AND TULARE CALIFORNIA.
HIS FATHER LEFT A LETTER IN
BECAME A NAVY. WHEN HE ENTERED
WORLD WAR TWO IN LATE NINETEEN
FORTY ONE. BOB IN HIS MOTHER
TRAVELED EXTENSIVELY DURING THE
WARS HIS FATHER TOOK PILOT
TRAINING AND LATER FLEW SEE
PLANES AND THE CARIBBEAN. AFTER
THE WAR BOB'S FAMILY MOVED TO A
DAIRY FARM NEAR MERCED. WHERE
THE SANDERS FAMILY GREW UP. NOT
FAR FROM MY HOME. BOB ATTENDED
WASHINGTON ELEMENTARY SCHOOL
MERCED HIGH SCHOOL MODESTO
JUNIOR COLLEGE AND CAL POLY SAN
LUIS OBISPO. AFTER BREAKING HIS
COLLARBONE DURING MERCED HIGHS
SCHOOLS STATE CHAMPIONSHIP
SEASON. BOB STARTED TO ASSIST
IN THE RADIO BROADCAST FOR THE
TEAM. THIS ULTIMATELY LED TO.
WORK AS A DJ ON LOCAL RADIO AND
AS THE POPULARITY OF ROCK AND
ROLL BOOMED IN THE LATE
NINETEEN FIFTIES THE DECADE OF
THE TEENAGER BOB TOOK ON THE
RADIO PERSONA OF RAPID ROBERT
SANDERS. EVENTUALLY BOB JOIN
THE CALIFORNIA NATIONAL GUARD
RECEIVE SPECIALIZED TRAINING AN
ARTILLERY SCHOOL IN OKLAHOMA.
AFTER COMPLETING HIS INITIAL
SERVICE BOB MET FORMER
ASSEMBLYMEMBER GORDON WYNTON
ALSO FROM MERCED ON THE FLIGHT
BACK TO CALIFORNIA AND ALL HE
OFFERED BOB A JOB IN A
SACRAMENTO OFFICE AND THUS
BEGAN HIS CAREER IN POLITICS.
WHAT ASSEMBLYMAN WENT DECIDED
NOT TO RUN IN NINETEEN SIXTY
SIX BOB SANDERS DECIDE TO TAKE
THE PLUNGE AND RUN FOR THAT
OPEN SEAT. DURING THE
CALIFORNIA PRIMARY BOB HAD THE
OPPORTUNITY TO TRAVEL IN HIS
DISTRICT AND DOWN TO SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA WITH PRESIDENTIAL
CANDIDATE ROBERT KENNEDY. BOB'S
CONVERSATIONS WITH SENATOR
KENNEDY OF ONE OF THE MOST
TREASURED MEMORIES. THAT HE
WOULD SHARE. BOB WORKED AS A
POLITICAL CONSOLE FOR MEMBER
RUSTY REYES CONGRESSMAN JIM
COST AS WELL AS A NUMBER OF
OTHER CALIFORNIA ELECTED
OFFICIALS HE ALSO WROTE SCRIPTS
DIRECTED AND- DID VOICE OVERS
FOR. NUMBER OF MILITARY
TRAINING FILMS. BOB EVENTUALLY
TOOK ON A FULL TIME POSITION
WITH THE CALIFORNIA ASSEMBLY
SPEAKERS OFFICE OF MEMBER
SERVICES WHERE HE CONTINUE TO
WORK UNTIL HE RETIRED TWENTY
SEVENTY. RETIREMENT LASTED ONLY
BRIEFLY HE SOON CAME BACK AS
RETIRED NEW AND TO ADVISE THE
CALIFORNIA SENATE DEMOCRATIC
CAUCUS. BOB WAS PRECEDED IN
DEATH BY HIS FATHER MARVIN HIS
MOTHER ANNA. AND MY YOUNGER
SISTERS HIS SURVIVED BY HIS
WIFE SUZANNE HIS DAUGHTER ERICA
AND HIS BROTHERS JIM AND JEFF.
BOB'S FRIENDS AND FAMILY CAME
TOGETHER REMEMBER OUR FRIEND
LAST FRIDAY. I ASK THIS
INSTITUTION WHICH BOB GAVE SO
MUCH OF HIS LIFE TO SERVING TO
REMEMBER HIS LEGACY TODAY.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU MISTER
GRAY. THANK YOU MA'AM. ALL
OTHER ITEMS. THE MOTION TO
ADJOURN HIS CARILLO MOVES AND
MISTER BONTA SECONDS AT THIS
HOUSE STANDS ADJOURNED UNTIL
THURSDAY JANUARY THIRTIETH AT
NINE AM WE ARE ADJOURNED.
FILE
ITEM NUMBER EIGHTEEN A. B.
THREE FORTY FIVE FROM I TO NOT
VOTING THE CHANGES NUMBER
GIPSON ASSEMBLY BILL THREE
FORTY FIVE I IT'S NOT VOTING.
FILE ITEM NUMBER FIFTY THREE AB
FOURTEEN FORTY ONE. I TO NOT
VOTING THE CHANGES ONLY MEMBER
GIPSON ASSEMBLY BILL FOURTEEN
FORTY ONE I TO NOT VOTING.